[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yo yo might check my check what's going
[Music]
[Music]
we got a little treat for you guys today
i worked all day yesterday off yeah
you know what i'm saying it's good for
what's going on y'all know what it is
i no doubt everybody say okay thank you
yobe i appreciate you bro appreciate
appreciate that
i know now so without further ado we got
some special things lined up for y'all
so
we gonna leave
and let the things happen
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hey what's happening uh y'all know my
name i know who i go by anyway a couple
of things that i want to see at the xbox
conference
all right since star field is being
delayed
i want to see perfect doc i want to see
the progression of that i want to see
like a 10 minute gameplay demo i mean
you got the time now so you know go
ahead and put that perfect dark game
play up for me uh guess trilogy
yes trilogy in particular some type of
announcement date some type of window
something that's going on um we need
gears two and three on pc because
they've never been there before
those are really the things that i would
want to see
you know and i want to thank you all for
the opportunity for letting my voice be
heard once again go by the name hustle
and motivate and i'm gone
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yo what's going on guys it's your boy
forte and i am here as one half of the
amazing damage per second podcast every
thursday 9 p.m rotates between my
channel and my homeboy slomo channel
slomo what's going on with you sir these
people want to know what your prediction
is for bethesda xbox and the e3 showcase
that they are doing on june 12th
first off i appreciate the iron lords
for uh uh getting our illustrious
opinions on this appreciate you guys uh
uh well i said guaranteed definitely
going to happen we're going to see a val
gameplay uh obsidian is a top-notch rpg
machine and they're going to be showing
us once again why they are one of the
best at what they do and then we're also
going to see uh something uh that we
haven't seen
yet at all and that's gonna be io
interactive's dragon game uh whatever
you want to call it fantasy dragon
whatever it's probably gonna be a teaser
trailer you know how they do but like
regardless we're gonna you know finally
get an announcement of that and then
whatever the title of the actual game is
yeah i i agree with you i think about is
definitely gonna be there in spades i
think it's going to end the show i think
we're going to finally see forza
motorsport 8 come to the show because
that is something turnt has been working
on it seems like since 2017
but the one thing i really think is
going to surprise people i think all of
the games like especially call of duty's
that aren't part of marketing deals for
playstation anymore i think those games
will show up in game pass because i
don't think we have to wait for this
acquisition to go through
to be able to get those games into this
service i think that would be a really
really good move for michael i mean the
older call of duty
i don't think we're gonna get the newer
ones because those still have
exclusivity when it comes to marketing
to sony but i think anything like
vanguard stuff that's like years out i
think those games are going to start
showing up in the service along with
like games like transformers in the
ninja turtles games and stuff like that
but those are just some of our
predictions if you want to hear more of
them we will be doing a live stream on
my channel this thursday right before
the conference you can go over all our
predictions in full every thursday 9 p.m
please come check us out appreciate the
iron loris you guys have a great week
and enjoy the show
and
it's on both our channels i said that
no you didn't okay it's on both our
channels
thank you peace
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what am i expecting that the xbox but
there's the game showcase well
let's start off with the obvious of
course i'm expecting to see some star
field game play some red fall game
i'm expecting to see summer vowel game
play
i'm actually expecting to see some type
of update with state of decay 3
maybe an update for perfect dark
um
i'm expecting to
see some you know some huge game pass
announcements
for the service
some some new games some new ips
announced like maybe compulsions
uh like whatever game they have been
working on and also i think one of the
coalition projects will be revealed at
this upcoming xbox but there's the game
showcase and one more thing i'm
expecting a huge surprise
what that surprise will be i don't know
but i'm expecting a huge surprise for
the show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
what i want to see from the microsoft
and bethesda showcase is pretty simple
it's a safe bet
it's something that i think will please
a lot of fans
it's part of the holy trinity that is
xbox when it comes to halo gears and
forza
gears
gotta come through i think they have to
drop
that gears of war original trilogy
remastered
marcus phoenix collection whatever you
want to call it it's been heavily
rumored
i think it needs to happen and it needs
to happen this year
give a release date come out in the fall
i feel like when it comes to xbox and a
lot of these games that have been
announced they've either been delayed
like starfield
or they're like fable
and perfect dark and and games like that
where they're just kind of far off
so i feel like microsoft and xbox needs
to drop something soon
something that's safe something that's
going to please fans
and uh gears is the one i think they got
to give us something so yeah that's
pretty much all i got that's really the
main thing
i feel
i want to see uh beyond that it would
just be maybe cherries on top maybe some
surprises maybe
something that i could you know really
knock my socks off to
i hope it's a good show
uh xbox i think they need a good show
and i'm looking forward to it so yeah
that's all i got enjoy the podcast
and shout out to iron lords talk to you
guys later
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
it's your boy kofi former host of press
art podcast but you can now find me on
twitter at press start kofi shout out to
my boy gaming addict he hit me up asking
me what's my most anticipated game uh
microsoft is gonna show at the xbox
showcase and it gotta be hellblade i
gotta see more hellblade the last
trailer that we saw at the game awards
looked absolutely incredible the visuals
were stunning and i really wanna see
where they take us i feel like microsoft
really needs this type of game on their
platform so i'm really looking forward
to hellblade 2. also avowed i got to see
some more about and you know what
perfect dark 2 perfect dark
honestly holds a special place in my
heart i used to kill that game on the
n64 so i'm really looking forward to
that too even though these games are a
little bit far away i'm hoping that
microsoft has you know some footage for
us and some gameplay for us to see so we
can you know satisfy our hunger and wait
for these amazing games that they got
coming out in the future
[Music]
what's up guys luca here
lucatio uh so i was asked to give my
predictions for the xbox showcase and my
predictions are
that it's going to be a
great show i'm hoping to see something
from machine games i'd like to see some
wolfenstein 3 but
i i mean i just think that we're going
to see what we're all expecting which is
probably some star field gameplay uh
probably something for a valve not sure
about it uh fabled at this point but
yeah
so
that's it for me
yeah
out of the chill
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
hey everybody i'm cold eastwood i'm an
xbox youtube content creator and the
iron lords asked me to give my most
desired things to come to the xbox game
showcase
and one of the things that nobody really
talks about but i think xbox needs to
grab is monoliths wonder woman that
superhero game not only the superhero
game but being an xbox exclusive i would
love to see that another thing that i'd
like to see that is something that's
been whispered and talked about is
fallout making a return because it's
going to be several years before we see
fallout but maybe fallout remasters
fallout new vegas fallout 3 something in
unreal engine 5 looking fantastic and
looking next generation another thing
that could be there but probably won't
be
but i think they need to show proof of
life for fable
fable needs to show something in engine
they may not be ready to show combat or
they may not be ready to show the game
to come out in the next year or so but
it's time for proof of life that fable
is looking fantastic from playground
games but the one thing that i need to
see is the thing i can't tell you about
the one big surprise that big brand new
shocking game some ip we've never heard
of something they show at the end of the
showcase a brand new game whole new
exclusive for xbox that one last thing i
gotta see it
[Music]
hey what's going on guys hope you guys
are doing well this is big cloud gaming
i'm the host of the rgt podcast on the
big cloud gaming youtube channel as well
as a writer for lords of gaming.net and
i am a former video producer under the
freelance program of ign so here's my
quick uh predictions for the xbox
showcase and this is coming from someone
who's mainly a playstation centric
youtube content creator so let's
definitely get into this so i'm going to
start off with the state of play
sony pretty much had a really really
great state of play with the
resident evil 4 reveal and the kalisto
protocol gameplay reveal i think
microsoft's in a perfect position with
their showcase to have something similar
of that of that nature for their side
the first game i would definitely throw
out here in terms of just being a really
cool reveal especially since a lot of
people are not really talking about it
now would be 007 i think io interactive
is really working on something special
and double-oh-seven is one of those
games that really really was
like so good back then if it's done
right you can possibly have you know
a game on the level of what you guys are
seeing uncharted with the crazy set
pieces and you know the high production
of what you guys see in the movies like
casino royale or no time to die this
would be a great showcase to showcase
that off and blow us away another game
that can definitely be showcased here
would be doom we haven't gotten any
updates since the last doom so kind of
makes me think that we might see a small
little snippet of something here related
to doom another game that i would also
like to see here as well because i've
been hearing a lot of stories about it
it's perfect dark perfect dark
definitely we we definitely need some
updates on this game not sure if it's
really you know coming along all the way
or whatever i'm still up and you know
i'm still in the dark as much as you
guys are obviously starfield and redfall
are gonna be here so no point in me
mentioning those so those are my quick
little uh predictions for the show for
those of you that want to find me it's
big cloud gaming youtube twitch twitter
and of course you can find me every
friday on my show the rhd podcast at 5
pm eastern standard time hope you guys
enjoyed the rest of the video and you
guys enjoy at the xbox showcase thanks
for watching
[Music]
what's up everybody matt here from fun
speculation on youtube you can find me
on twitter at fun speculation also on
youtube fun speculation where we have
game streams lots of podcasts and more
uh stop by hit the notification bell to
find out whenever we're gonna go live
appreciate you all now hey i was asked
what do i want to see
from xbox bethesda's showcase now
there's a lot i want to see but i'll
start off with this right i
really need to see gameplay from the
previously announced big time titles
that they got cooking state of decay 3
avowed
fable
perfect dark
we've already seen hellblade i'll pass
on that one i think we can wait till
next year besides that i want these big
titles that they've already been
announced two years ago a lot of them to
give us a glimpse into what these games
actually are i want to see it it's a
must for me
next i absolutely
love new game announcements
these shows for me are all about new
game announcements and if xbox has as
many projects in the works that
everybody says they do
that we all know about with all of these
teasers of all these projects all these
developers are talking about everything
they got going on i want to see
lots of new game announcements i want to
see more new game announcements than
we've ever seen before i want to find
out what all these project names are
real names are i want to see the game
names i want to see even if it's a few
cgi trailers i got to see this stuff i
got to know what the future of xbox is
like for the next four to five years
don't be shy it's okay
give us a slate
what are you all working on that's
that's what i want to see
from the xbox bethesda showcase
have a good one everybody
[Music]
so
[Music]
yo what's up lords you wanna know my
predictions yeah all right all right i i
i know you're a family show so uh i need
to maybe get out my system hey lord
attic you
[ __ ]
two hours later
five hours later all right all right
what games what games do i get you gotta
bring it you gotta bring it i wanna i
wanna see oh i wanna see some madness i
want to see quite that's right quake
this is quake all night bring it back
quick i'm sick and tired of this stupid
generation of fortnite players you get
shot to turn around and build with the
taj mahal 0.3 microseconds give us quake
oh man that's right can you imagine
quick what are you doing it's soft like
you got the talent maybe another dupe
but i want quick
to be quick give that one more just one
game yeah cog you want one more game
just give us the one more single player
third person sad dad simulator so these
playstation 5
christopher christopher say hey
christopher would you
what you want to talk to all
right xbox got nuggets get out of here
forza i want to see ray tracing you
gotta shut fours and that's coming what
about all these other games huh about
well you know what show phantom dust
that's right phantom dust some miles
don't panic and shut the f oh you know
what
i need some sauce
conker
that's right not banjo-kazooie
forgot i just want xbox
to show gameplay
just show gameplay
please show gameplay
just
show
gameplay
please
lord addict
edit this you suck
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
what's good good people if you don't
know who i am it's your boy lyndon aka
right hand zeus that dude from 108
dragons tv where you get all your fresh
gaming news but let's get into my xbox
bethesda predictions thanks for having
me attic now
first thing i'm going to say what would
it be in the xbox press conference if
they don't announce new games that will
be dropping into game pass you already
know the game pass knight train is real
baby you know what he's doing in these
gaming streets and number two
predictions from your boy lemon
i think we gonna get some
gameplay from starfield yes i know it
missed the holiday season but yes we're
gonna get some gameplay and number three
predictions from your boy limiteds
we're gonna get frozen motorsport launch
date this holiday season
yes
[Music]
that nobody knew about that's being made
announced
attic thanks for having me hit that like
and subscribe runaway dragons tv baby
[ __ ]
[Music]
what's happening everybody k-mega 405
coming to you live from the fall five
you can catch me on twitter at kmega4 my
youtube channel kmega405
my twitch hey mega 405
fight night sundays every sunday night 8
30 p.m central time we play all
different types of fighters speaking of
fight night the fighter the boxing game
that needs to make a comeback that will
be announced
on the xbox stage
another game that is long overdue
is
killer instinct 2
that needs to be
brought back to life you need to hear it
come on field let that happen
um
ninja gaiden
also
college football would be dope to be
announced on
of the xbox stage and then some classics
give us a remake to jade empire
also
cameo bring us a new cameo or another
remake i think that that would be
amazing everybody have a good one take
care of yourself happy sunday
[Music]
what's going on everybody this is k
asante tko asante on twitter host of the
gaming circle podcast i was asked what
do i want microsoft to provide me for
this show on the 12th what would make me
happy as a gamer
let me be honest i was a little
disappointed you know when we heard
about the news of them not releasing
their two marquee titles so since that
time my expectations have been you know
uh
properly calibrated so for me personally
uh i really enjoy the indies that
they've provided uh some of the other
some of the games that are off off the
beaten path so
as long as they can provide me some new
gems that i didn't know i wanted i think
i'll be all right with it you know uh i
have been looking out really really
looking forward to like atomic heart i
know that due to you know re reasons
with the world that might not hit the
date that it's supposed to hit games
like that i think
will kind of come out of left field and
really surprise people so i'm hoping
that with those marquee titles not
available that we get some surprises
that we wouldn't have thought about you
know i know that there's an idea out
there that maybe there are some surprise
amazing games that they have been
keeping under wraps and i hope maybe we
see some of that as well but for me
personally yeah it's just the new the
interesting heck you know maybe some
remix i'm i'm there for it right i've
been i recently got a steam deck so i've
been uh playing a lot of uh retro games
and some old games that i haven't played
in a while so give me that fable
remaster collection right give me the
the marcus phoenix the rumored marcus
phoenix collection as long as there's a
reason for that for that uh remake to
exist meaning you know give give me an
unreal five rendition of these games or
something to that effect something that
makes having those games available in
the new form worth it so yeah honestly
um for me personally you know as long as
i see them actually trying to
cultivate me as a consumer even after
the the unfortunate news that has
dropped about certain
aaa games not being available as long as
i see them really pulling out all the
stops uh i've said this on a few shows
before as long as i see them taking a
kitchen sink approach and literally like
just giving me things that i didn't know
i wanted and hey 2022 is not that much
of a wash hey there's so many other
games to play i will personally be super
happy so that's that's my take on it uh
i i can't wait to see what's going on on
the 12th and i can't wait to watch all
the reactions and all that stuff
including for those from the ilp so
salute to y'all thank you very much
[Music]
middle aged game guy here you know where
you can find me at the middle aged game
guy that's with the gy at the end on
twitter i do not do youtube i like to do
everything on twitter because i don't
like to follow the rules and let me tell
you something the way that i look at
this xbox bethesda show what i want to
see happen is i want to see you take
care of 2022 i already know what's
coming in 2023 and 2024 and 2025 and
beyond it's not that i know when they're
coming out but i know that i'm already
invested in the platform during that
time so therefore that being the case
what i want to know is what's going to
happen this year i want to know what
defcon 5 kind of order has been coming
out this year now that you know that
starfield redfall is not coming how are
you going to take care of the consumer
this year as an xbox fan that's what i
want to see i want to see that all those
series s's that have been selling every
single month after month winning npd's
and winning mpd's those people need
something to play i understand that
there's already almost 500 games in the
game past service right now but i want
to know as a hardcore i want to see how
you're going to take care of me someone
who buys almost everything and
is involved in the ecosystem and those
already invested like i said in the long
term so that's what i want to see as an
xbox fan at this show
yes i want to see some gameplay of games
like indiana jones and fable and things
like that i want to see those things and
avowed okay and perfect dark and all of
those games and even a little bit of
starfield and red fall i want to see all
that too however
that is not this year i am paying for a
service this month next month the next
month the next month all the way until
2023 and beyond and when those games are
coming out i get it but for the dollars
that i'm spending now and for the
dollars of those casual consumers who
just definitely win
the long term and they're the ones that
win the war not us not the 15 to 25
percent it's the 70 75 80
of the casuals that win it i want you to
want i want to see what you're going to
do for them i want you to see what
you're going to do for me for this year
so that's what i want to see i'm excited
to see yes i want to see those games but
at the same time i want to see what
you're bringing to me
this year in game pass and i want to see
what i'm going to be playing for the
rest of the year thank you very much
everybody enjoy the show
[Music]
gamers what is going on it is pong soul
hey look if you don't know me find me
pog soul xbox pong soul on twitter
that's right you can find me co-hosting
the living split screen co-hosting pm in
the pm i'm on panel over at xbox factor
podcast xbox ultimate and the shop
podcast that's right i love talking
about games and this entire industry and
i love this community so first things
first shout out big thank you to the
iron lords for this opportunity honored
humbled privileged to be here talking to
you right now because i know they're
inviting some of the best the best in
this community crazy that i'm in this
but man thank you all for this listen
they invited me to come talk to you
about the xbox bethesda showcase june
12th what am i expecting to see there
that's right it's christmas time for us
gamers this is some of the best time of
the year because we get surprised and
wowed so guess what let's get down to
business i want to see gameplay gameplay
and more gameplay from this showcase i
want to see what all these teams have
been working on of course they're not
going to show to us all of it all of it
to us but listen i want to see as much
as possible so give me gameplay but
specifically the wizards at obsidian
have been working on about and i want to
see this brand new ip from one of my
favorite studios
i can't wait brand new rpg man i just
want to see and get my hands on it but
listen i'll start out by just
seeing it at the showcase then
this is gonna be a little out there
people but they didn't give me any
guidelines for this so i'm gonna have a
little fun in speculation town right now
that's right machine games wolfenstein
three i think they've been working on it
i think it's ready to show and i think
it's gonna be at this showcase i want
them to finish this trilogy right so
give me wolfenstein three from machine
games man that will make one heck of a
showcase and then final real big wish
here
that's right real big one zenimax online
studios makers of the elder scrolls
online i think they've been working on a
new ip or at least i hope they have been
and i want to be star wars i want a
brand new star wars mmo let me be a jedi
let me be a sith lord let me be a bounty
hunter whatever i want to be
man i want xenomax online to announce a
brand new star wars mmo listen no matter
what happens the showcase is gonna be
amazing i want you all to enjoy the rest
of the show this is the golden age of
gaming people play what you love love
what you play i'm gonna talk to you all
real soon
[Music]
[Music]
all right my check people might check
people
a little fun you know what i'm saying
while in the room
still going on it's crazy
yeah we gotta get some couples
[Music]
different from the community you know
much loved everybody who participated
some submissions could not get in you
know last minute but we still want to
thank people who still say hey they want
to contribute
i want to personally thank the people
that were dealing with my
[Music]
warrior drop those controllers we
outside yeah then we got a two dollar
super trap from dollar taco this xbox
showcase will be the a3 of dreams
then we got a five dollar super chat
from dawn to talk or saying sony had
their best day to play ever
they finally got to see tier nintendo
direct levels jim ryan is my heart
slowly and surely
uh improvement ps
then we got a five dollar super draft
from jd gamer shout out to the lords and
ladies of the round thanks for starting
us off right this afternoon don't forget
to like that like button folks
then we got a twenty dollars to project
from dragon heart yobe tv
i'm gonna say this again mark my words
goldeneye
seven hd remake will be at the show
and showcase if not i will get all my
knees in scope and sent a key
it's going to be a great show hashtag
peace love
life to the deaths of gate or to the
deities of gaming let's go all right yo
let's not read anymore they say the
music so we're gonna switch over
[Music]
a proclamation
[Music]
i'ma just chill and watch them eat
snacks in the attic i wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young wolf
but then they would mistake me for
addict if i can imagine it's cool to
give you some advice then invite your
girl to your squadron cause if you don't
give her that option you're gonna be
single player like siren you're gonna
get tossed in the bushes by king david
royalty not a pretender detrimental to
an elemental what's the avatar to a knee
bender i gotta be me though i know it's
my destiny works incognito who cares if
you fly if you're still a mosquito you
swear you ain't something but really
you like to collect stuff and that's
cool but i got bad news even if you
really was that jew king david still be
the king of the statues since the
juvenile i've been cursed with a curse
to be musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in the crucible was it in nothing
it's cool and it's beautiful we let you
know that your dreams are pursuable
whatever you want to do then is doable
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a lord's day
[Music]
all right all right mic check mic check
real quick from everybody before we get
testing testing yes yes boom you know
what i'm saying
hello hello hello
addict talk to the people real quick
we'll make sure we had a whole bunch of
little difficulties with some audio
what's going on guys do i sound better
now
[Laughter]
[Music]
we got the dog with us what's going on
you know what i'm saying we got a lot of
stuff going on but again
hear ye hear ye and we are live
welcome to the iron laws podcast llc and
also live on lords of gaming.net episode
number 260 260 oh and it's another
glorious sunday and we are back at the
round table on the lord's date i'm very
excited about this xbox royalty showing
up in the realm as we have the xbox and
bethesda showcase prediction series so
we gonna get right into it
i want to introduce a lord who is
absolutely no stranger to the realm of
the iop and was one of the very first
and reputable lords in the xbox
community to give ilp that official
godfather-like co-side
introducing the xbox og of social media
and the panelists of the rdx and txr
podcast
the lord of project natal you better
know what that is
fellow xbox live beta tester and always
reppin our first place let's go bets
live from strong island and making his
return into the realm of the lords
mommy
lord tim dawg are we doing it yeah man i
feel like you're bruce buffer right now
like before the fight like getting ready
uh man happy to be here uh great show
uh you know every year we do this and
every year you guys grow and every year
uh it's another uh introduction to the
iron lords and and uh it's just great to
see how much you guys grown
from when i think i was on your second
show
um and just to see where you guys are
now and how your network is just booming
and just everything you're doing uh
really great to see and uh my pleasure
always a tradition to be here for this
day to uh
talk about xbox and see where they stand
so i'll just my pleasure to be here
thank you for having me
and uh let's have a good show you
already know much love man yeah we we
were ilg addict remember we were iron
lords gaming and we were it was a it was
an intervention show to convince people
to play destiny
[Laughter]
yeah
it tim was jumped on man
that that wasn't my uh brightest idea
yeah you guys were like having every
show was destiny and i was like oh i
mean i love you guys i'm not a big
destiny guy but how oh come on
who could come with it
much love to the dog you already know
and of course we have a lord who is
absolutely family to the rub of the iop
and whose infectious enthusiasm for the
xbox platform and gaming as a whole
easily translates to one of the hardest
working content creators within our
community
introducing the creator of the double
barrel gaming youtube channel and the
host of prime time gaming x vlog
breakfast with boom and the xbox factor
podcast
new york city's finest and officer
friendly of the podcast community
who will never forget his mr lee used
game training roots
live from new rock and making his return
into the realm of the lord
my man lord boob stick excel how we
doing sir uh we're doing great this is
this is this is a fun time folks this is
a fun time i'm happy to be back proud to
be a part of something so special
if you thought last year's uh uh you
know guesstima guesstimation of what i
think could be happening wait til you
hear what i have to say this year it's
inducing uh again when you you know it's
going to be good when you write it and
you get goosebumps so i'm ready to rock
and roll i'm ready to ride listen man no
one gets the community more pumped and
excited
look we got people coming in addict just
do me a solid cause um a couple of
people say hey if we're just gonna do
that again yeah let's do it there's only
like five and you're still out so turn
yourself down just a little bit but um
well yeah yeah let's get let's get the
thumb up again let's get the the realm
they proper read or the chats
is that better no you're still loud
you're boring crazy absolutely yeah
no
[Music]
we'll figure it out we'll figure it out
in the meantime super chats talks off
[Laughter]
we just we just got a police on them
police officers
shout out to one away in the chassis
shout out to aurora wolf wasting the
blender what about now yes
[Music]
let me grab this member chat real quick
because i can't see these in this little
thing we got a a member trap from smitty
smith been a member for 28 months over a
year man over two years wow shout out to
him salute to the lords
and special guests to chat shout out to
the sony state of play
uh play that showed all the games i get
to play on xbox hashtag book x
savagery already all right so let me go
ahead and read these again uh so we got
to shoot our super chat from cobweb
dirt what's up brother we got a five
dollar super trap from braille console
warrior
drop those controllers we outside we got
a two dollar super trap from don otaku
this xbox showcase will be the e3 of
dreams
we got a five dollar strat from don
otaku sony had the best state of play
ever they finally get to see uh tier
nintendo uh nintendo levels jim ryan is
my heart
fully but shirley and proving
king
we got we got a five dollar shooter from
jd gamer shout out to the lords and
ladies of the realm thanks for starting
us off right this afternoon
don't forget to hit that like button
folks
hit that like button folks we got a 20
super chat from dragon heart yobe tv
i'ma say this again mark my words go
tonight007
hd remake will be at the showcase if not
i will get my niece sculptured and send
it to king it's gonna be a great show
hashtag peace love life to the deities
of gaming let's go
five dollar super chat from neo metal
it's gonna be a long show let me get
this popcorn
got a five dollar super chat from dawn
otaku i'm in church right now sneaking
in the podcast
god
can wait for the lord
all right then we got a
20 super trap from free r kelly oh
it ain't looking too good for microsoft
sony state of play killed it you gotta
say everything
you said like they said
whatever
the best thing about it is i get to play
all your games with the xbox controller
shut up now
that's messy all right
ten dollar super trap from free r kelly
it's over
game pass falling off
halo dead
microsoft ain't got no games sony is
still top dog oh he outside you know i
love the fact when he scrounges up some
changes together to super chat
it'd be like four weeks that he'd be
like i'm back though
you know what that reminds me of that
reminds me of crash bandicoot standing
out with the megaphone
oh yeah this is just yelling yeah yeah
the outside listen shout out freon kelly
man it's always good to see your
backpack we got a ten dollars
creation they put them right ten dollar
super chat for jd gamer yes my
predictions loss of indies and double a
games dropping in game past day and date
this year and beyond final fantasy 7
with expansion announced more japanese
support
one killed super one killer surprise
game and king is right
percent of the time oh god that's up on
that one he pulled in he pulled a little
little spice on that put the stats up
thank you got a five dollar spread from
dawn otaku and it's more like
eighty-five percent
xbox exclusives for the rest of the year
grounded 1.0 hammer dark side score
forza motorsports uh pendament
project yeah bellefy
belfry
and more smaller indies
got a 20 super chat from paris lockhart
oh just swinging in real quick to say
combo breaker
combo have a great show i said paris i
see what you're doing
[Laughter]
salute to you salute to killer instinct
and i i see what you do brother great
games of our destiny recently had a ton
of fun playing referee addict in the
lords that was fun shout out to megatron
of them as well shout out to xbox clown
in the building
got a five dollar super chat from 108
dragon tv hi guys no you got to say hi
guys
[Laughter]
[Music]
let's hope this showcases
fire we'll be watching with colt and
others in l.a oh salute should we been
in l.a already man it's just if the
world was the world yeah got a two
dollar super trap from forza legends yo
king
you ready for that outriders dlc i am
sir yes i am
then we got to fight our streamers from
donald talker shout out to the best
place
xbox podcast out there can't wait for
this five hour prediction podcast
you don't wish that on the whistle uh we
got we got a two dollar street from
so-so
so-so all my favorites on one show this
is legendary oh love thank you got a
five dollar superstar from fun
speculation safe bet prediction we are
going to have a heck of a lot of fun
the next week shout out to the lords
boom and tyndall going to be a great
show shout out the mav love baths i
think he works harder than me that's
your
restored by life number one xbox podcast
even though my a button don't work on my
elite controller
like we said
guys i see i see you in the chat guys uh
we we didn't we didn't edit your your
your video yes you got you got approval
you got the source was approved you did
a good job sir
got a member chat uh framatic eagle been
a member for 31 months dude much love
uh much love the iop what's good boom
and tim dawg let's
let's go
looking forward to the laughs
oh my keeps throwing it back down okay
then we got a i got you serena
to cerebral palsy awesome chat sunday
fun day to the lords in the chat
smitty smith final super chat ps fanboys
all i have is spider-man pc no you don't
the book of x
george tj 10 super chat hi guys morning
lords i hope we see fable forza horizon
expansion and halo battle royal and
avowed keep being awesome guys and then
pragmatic eagle 10 with the sticker
number one fan salute
drawing tj 5 super chat everyone hit the
like button yes hit the like button
please would like to do something
special for community shout out to code
eastwood in the chat i see you brother
he's at home today watching lords live
you already know what it is we got a lot
going on so did you get the ten dollar
sticker yeah i got the ten dollar
sticker with the little choice going on
so i think we could we caught up we
would try our best you know what i'm
saying so we are missing one
horseman of gaming yeah shout out to
elephant oh lord two dollars super chat
from let me play with your joystick
no song today puts pants back on yeah
this is the move for him this is the
move he's still going through it he
tried his best he we may get out we may
get a campaign we'll see
yeah i know i know but yeah shout out to
him so we still got you know three
horsemen of gabriel there's some other
arriving potential guests coming into
the realm my co-host with cole knows my
brother from another mother the
difficult game conqueror lord of his own
world and the hop of the young wolf my
man lord addict of the attic show how we
doing sir
doing pretty good first thing i want to
say is i appreciate everyone that
submitted a video for our starting zoom
screen uh you know
i i'm going to put all of their
credentials after the podcast in the
description for people watching after
the podcast has already uh has already
went off uh you know it's a good show
man we have we have a good show set up
we actually have some uh some cameo
people gonna pop in i think you guys
might be surprised uh king you know one
of them king
you know one
we saw my pax east
[Music]
so i appreciate everyone for coming
through man uh we're gonna have a good
show man got some good guests having
kojima on oh my god
anyway
and of course we have the incredible
hulk of this aka the xs gamer
the prophet of xbox swamy
he always killed me
king of the statues who demands nothing
less than that premium experience and is
the leader of the fraud alert movement
beloved lord k good to see you
oh man it's great to see y'all too
had a great successful combat talk with
the king last night
devin haney went inside and
gave a master class of a performance
beautiful jab beautiful right hand
beautiful ring generalship he didn't
allow cambosis to do anything that
camposes wanted to do and it was
something magnificent to see
it is the undisputed lightweight
champion of the world he has all four
belts
and
that
at that age is incredible something to
behold so yeah 23. yeah
absolutely nuts all right so um i
finished my fortnight season uh pass i
got um
whatchamacallit uh i got my doctor
strange out so um like a hundred and
something level 100 or something now and
um
then i started doing a little bit of
eldering plus jump back on my destiny i
had yo
first of all um okay let's get it
bungee why are you in my wallet the way
you are
why you do this the way that you do
first of all we had a ship in there that
i had to buy and i had to have money to
get that right so i didn't have any
silver so i had to run to the store and
go buy it
i got to be fly i came back dude
the king is back i'm back so i had to
buy clothes and i had to buy a new ship
all right so when they see me they
fold up
right all right so that's what's up oh
that was twenty dollars um
and then i went it was a mission so i
went and got all my stuff and stuff and
uh there's a mission there and i said
okay let me click it because i wanna do
the new dungeon they say yo you ain't
got keys yeah yeah i said what keys what
do you mean keys yeah twenty dollars
get down get down and lay down
it's either you wanna play or you don't
and i was like i wanna play so you want
to pay
all right all right i see how y'all
doing with me so i paid for that i was
playing destiny with um
hot monkey loving yesterday salute and
yo this new season i'm loving it i'm
loving what they're doing
with the um the the pyro
yeah sola
it is incredible the way you can
manipulate things and do your grenades
so everybody is a little bit different
in the game you can really stat to be a
unique character and i think destiny is
on to something better it changed
because it was going on a linear path
and now it just branched off into
something incredible i love it but
you're kicking somebody from the block
them pulled up on us that's my no god is
this the legendary hip hop gamer the
ocean
danger number one journalist quickly i
changed the game up oh my god baby
oh lord baby you know what it is when i
come around
i love y'all you know what it
brother yo real quick man i was tired
you got first of all it's great to see
you you know what i'm saying we see you
moving and shaking all the time always
love so real quick again i don't know
how much time we got you so i just want
to know what your energy is for the show
and like where you at you know what i'm
saying as far as your little prediction
what you what you got cooking hip hop
for xbox so yo you know so crazy like so
the xbox showcase is the same day as
summer jam
so i'm actually gonna be a giant stadium
watching everybody perform while i got
my phone
watching xbox do they think
you know i don't care because yo yo this
this is my life yo i got to do that so
here's a couple of predictions that i do
got you
i believe we gonna see the first
gameplay or snippet of gameplay for
indiana jones so i'm looking forward to
seeing that that joint look masterful
like they pull it off right that joint
could be a whole that could that could
be
uh
i wouldn't say their answers are
uncharted but they're having more games
than that like yeah to be action
adventure and that cinematic stuff you
know what i'm saying so that's one thing
that i think is gonna be crazy another
thing is forza motorsport
so
i believe you're gonna see that
finally uh in game play and if you look
at the you know trailer and everything
that they had before in terms of the
in-game um engine it looks incredible in
terms of that but you know how it is you
gotta see what it's like in practice but
it looks like it's gonna be crazy and
forza is a great franchise for xbox so
that's gonna be important now i believe
you're gonna get uh a teaser of the
actual splinter cell game oh
yeah boom like that
so not like a feature like like sam
fisher featured in the game yeah that
ghost recon
yeah you know what i'm saying i think i
believe you're gonna get the first ever
little teaser of what cell's gonna do
and be like and then ubisoft
you know show you everything like you
know what i'm saying but i believe
you'll get that teaser on xbox i think
it'll be unique to do it since that's
the platform that said it all factual
you know what i'm saying because back in
the day it was sam fisher solid snake
that was the battle now i mean so um so
that's that and then lastly
i believe you're going to get the first
glimpse of sega's deal with xbox in
terms of the cloud gaming super game
and i believe that they're going to
showcase uh azure in a certain way so
i'll give you example like when you look
at um
a flight simulator uh how they they
stream all that data from the cloud like
in real time for game play that right
there is just like scratching the
surface because um shout out to my band
david perry yeah david perry um you know
with guy kai all that stuff back in the
day uh he was talking a lot about um and
he made a lot of investments uh in cloud
gaming as well because he was from until
we get to the point where cloud gaming
data can be a part of your gaming
experience on on um on the fly that's
when you're really gonna see it so
that's another reason why these systems
was built the way it was built when it
comes to the uh ssd and just having that
streaming technology because we're
starting to see a lot of it now and you
see a lot of it where actually clank um
uh rift apart where like everything is
just
it's there like yeah you pull it into
the world entertainment everything is
there so uh you're gonna see that on a
whole nother scale with the way azure
microsoft azure pulls that together with
sega so i believe those are like my
predictions okay on what you're gonna
see and um yeah man i think it's gonna
be insane man i i really believe they're
gonna have a a really really solid
showcase not not just because just being
a fan of xbox i think because they need
to um
love those predictions very strong
brother good thank you for taking the
time out brother you have no idea it's
always always good to see you bro let
let them know where you at wait where
they can find what's cooking what you
got beside besides summer jam what else
is cooking oh yeah besides that so um
well i i just made a cameo in my first
movie oh which is uh we need to talk so
it's streaming on amazon prime right now
and um it's on 2b tv and it's going to
be on other platforms too so i'll make a
small camera your appearance but you
know it's the beginning of other things
that i'm working on you know what i'm
saying so that's hip-hop gamer in the
movie world
now y'all seen me interview a lot of
movie stars oh yeah all the time
so now it's time to get it you know what
i mean yep
brother that's that's one right there
okay that's awesome
i'm working uh i just finished writing a
song okay for a new
project
hip hop project that right gabers like
so you'll see you'll see
you'll see this in november oh like in
november yeah you'll see this in
november so i just did a song so you'll
see it in november boom that's that and
uh
another thing that i would say another
thing that i would probably say is
uh
so when 2k 23 yeah comes out and stuff
like that like later this year yeah uh
there's some things that i'm looking to
lord willing
can launch
with that okay that's going to be very
competitively
driven because i feel like well i can't
stand up i can't stand saying i feel
like yeah like because everybody says
that so i don't like saying so what i
would say is
in not just uh
in this industry but in society there's
been this big
fear of competition like the moment
there's anything competitive
it's automatically labeled as oh well
it's toxic or we don't want no like
problems another like right it doesn't
mean it's problems uh one of the things
that i think is a big issue especially
like you know in gaming as well
is the very thing that we benefit off of
is also the very thing we try to
make it make it seem like it's bad so if
you look at so if you look at uh there
would be no playstation if it wasn't for
nintendo because of the things that
nintendo's actual factual and when
nintendo and sega was battling we
wouldn't got the games that we got if it
wasn't for their level of competition
we got to make each other better like
you know what i'm saying like when it
comes to what y'all do with iron laws
podcast there's a lot of people right
now sitting down studying y'all admiring
y'all
and they want to compete with y'all they
don't want to see y'all not be
successful right they want to they want
to be able to elevate too and they're
going to learn but they're going to
compete in fact um king was talking
about um
you know uh battle talk like the boxing
talk
and then after the fight they showed mad
love to one another devin haney put on
that masterpiece
you know what i'm saying so my thing is
uh when it comes to being competitive
uh there's nothing wrong with being
competitive being a-hole
i respect that yeah so
there's something that i'm looking to do
with 2k 23.
and there's a
program there's a app that's it's
already out but like kind of like silent
right now
but when it dropped in a big way
think about and one basketball back in
the day oh yeah futures
you know rocking all of that
let's say we let's say we are taking it
back to the s oh
in october and um be looking to bring 2k
into that
world in a different way so that's all i
can say right now dawg but other than
that i love y'all man i love you this is
crazy you already know what it is i'm
gonna talk to y'all later i already know
the legendary
hip hop gamer on your hot dog seven
every day that's my word
brooklyn in the villages stand up that
was love you already know of course we
got me
little cognitive are you doing all those
things if i was doing it but i'm high
you're a busy man
salute to hip-hop man i ain't gonna say
too much of myself but uh salute to uh
definitely duke uh we had a good one man
shout out to the legendary xbox two man
thor who's in the chat who's complaining
why he didn't get invited i gave you a
break man you been you did your podcast
you did you did chatter days with miles
you did us at the friday duke for daily
three hours i had to give you a break
man but salute to him salute to the
legendary just jessica and it was an
absolutely fun prediction show spicy
spicy predictions go check that out
should be up live down on youtube if you
get a chance but you're supposed to be
here but then after that you watch
but
after that oh we got shout out to my
brothers for our destiny brother shout
out to bontes shout out to thai guy
travis we had destiny family in the
building shout out to cb gray scarole
nine teaser teddy is it was a movie we
talked about rift all the stuff going on
with that and of course all my brothers
that's gonna be in orlando next week
with me uh gcx i'm looking forward to
seeing y'all um yeah as far as people
games just been duality dungeon shout
out that citizen shout out to attic
we've been doing that halfway to my iron
lord title that's what's that let's get
a couple of super chats and then you
know we got to get the show on the road
um i'm up to sinjitsu sage
um hello gentlemen i'm currently still
recovering from all those xbox titles
showed off on at state of play jesus
that i got crazy horse uh follow-up chat
just wanted to remind people first party
playstation games are timed exclusives
oh okay all right all right attic i
think i got jump but let me go up a
little bit after that yep i'm good now i
got um damien welcome to the realm
salute little bronze italian clouds four
guys recorded what's going on 10 super
chat all hail the king shout out to the
hip hop gamer one of the realest out
there my brother tim dawg have a great
show it clowns in the building clowns
again lemon 108 dragon tv tcl equals lct
lemon cosines this oh wow
wow that's what we doing
that was a [ __ ]
that was a good one
jumped into the new york city video
games version of end game my iop bros
with my fellow nypd retiree mr boom tim
dawg and hip-hop gamer awesome king we
want that hulk unboxing have a great
show hashtag xbox
that's a good one lord metroid remember
for nine months i don't want no
exclusive exclusives talking nonsense on
the 12th show me the games the vow is
the highlight for me shout out to the
lords and guests you already know and i
think the last one for right now
drawingtj 10 on superchat one of the
best podcasts out here thank you brother
what's up do i sound fine yeah you sound
good okay all right cool let's get into
it man so no polls no fluff we we you
know what we're here for assault would
say we got to get into it but i want to
set it up really quickly um just kind of
like a field i want to start with the og
you know tim dawg kind of the state of
xbox for you personally 2022 you know
obviously coming in the show we know
about you know some major game delays
already you know with red fall star
field but like what's the feel what's
the vibe for you tim dawg heading into
this showcase
well to be honest uh i look back and i
look back at times when we did these
prediction shows
and i used to have you know uh you know
i was optimistic when they had four
studios
and you know now
you look you look at the situation now
where
um
without activision it's 23 studios and
some of these studios now are four years
old since they've all owned them to 2018
um
i feel confident i really i really feel
like
you know in the past they really had to
pass things to work
whereas now they can really if they want
to push the lever they can push the
lever they can do whatever they want
because they have a ton of stuff on the
pipeline obviously they announced all
the stuff that they've announced a lot
of people are saying they want to see
gameplay i think that that uh you know
we'll talk later about that but um stuff
like that and them listening
uh is what they do and i think that
that's gonna show itself
and overall um listen
i saw what happened when the
when starfields
to be honest i was a little surprised
xbox fans went bananas and i get and i
get it to a point but you also have to
have a little bit of a a you know a
little bit of
you can't be that short-sighted and i
get the frustration believe me
but
bro
they've got so much stuff
that they they're gonna be coming out
with
um and i know people don't hear about
2023 and
and stuff like that we're not going to
talk about that but just
have a little patience
uh i really feel like
[Music]
they they know what's going on they're
listening they're probably watching the
show as we speak got paris here already
and uh listen all that stuff is is
listened to we're listening to
our our issues are listened to and then
they try to hear it you know um
basically when this when the whole thing
went down
the sentiment to me was well we got to
fix it we got to make it right and
that's the stuff that you want to hear
you don't want to hear oh
uh you know uh the xbox fans is just
being this this is what you want to hear
them say
okay we screwed up we want to get a
writing um i think that they're on that
course and i really feel like
for the first time ever as an xbox fan
i don't have i really don't have doubts
i don't know
yeah it's just super confident i mean
listen i think the biggest thing for
them in the upcoming future is this
activision deal i i really believe if
they get this activision deal tremendous
um they're just pretty much set but yeah
i like comparing to either
the either
other years when i was talking to king
david at e3s
and he was like you know we gotta you
know we gotta phil has to show this
stuff and this is not
i just looked and they had four studios
man remember those days and we still had
we still backed them and you know now
it's like they got 23 studios
50 games supposedly in development um
it's like
it's like a totally different ball game
and uh i just feel confident and that's
for the bottom of my heart i'm not
telling you that as a you know trying to
push anything i'm just super confident
that's what's up not a favor that's
that's your vibe i want to speak the
boom man you know again not the
predictions yet
just the state of xbox in 2022 for you
personally leading into this showcase
look i i've said this on my show here's
the thing um
microsoft finds themselves in a very
unique position uh and it's a difficult
one
last year publisher of the year through
meta right metacritic uh gave them them
one slot and they deserved it
um
they they come off a year where
first party is leading the charge
is everywhere uh halo infinite whether
you you you like it or you don't
the game's amazing both in multiplayer
and single player forza did numbers that
we've never seen before and everything
else just followed suit they opened up
to they opened up the 2022 campaign with
the announcement of activision no one
saw that coming no one on this panel no
one in the chat and we have a lot of
software i got to give out to the solve
though
he's the only one that i've never known
that okay so
maybe just the one the reality is he's
the one in the world that's i just want
to give about my brother his flowers no
one would have saw that coming
so now we're all writing this wave of of
of excitement and then then we get then
we wipe out right we wipe out with star
field and we wipe out with uh red fall
being delayed now is it the biggest
thing in the world for it to happen no
um delays happen that's that's a thing
yeah and everybody wants this game to be
as
it has to be right it can't ship with
bugs it needs to be right
and you know i talked to chaos ante
almost every day on the phone and we uh
we came to this understanding shout out
to chaos ante who of course was on the
opening of the show
that the way that they did this
this rip off the band-aid
and again i said this before and i know
people from microsoft listening i'm
always fair like if i'm going to give if
i'm going to criticize i'm going to be a
real person i'm and i'm fair no doubt um
i thought the way it was done it
bothered me as an xbox fan because it's
something
that if if you see me throw up a couple
of words and a thumbnail you say well
that's an unprofessional right there
right that guy's just a youtuber right
when you are
a multi-trillion dollar company and you
have two of the biggest games that are
that are coming out this year announced
to come out this year you throw a couple
of words and a thumbnail i'm gonna be
honest with you that seemed very very
like nonchalant half-hearted i didn't
like the way that went down
uh so i'm going to be honest with you it
kind of took the wind out of my sails i
respect that i expect the honest okay
i'm sorry you know i mean listen
we're expecting
my prediction for this year and a lot of
people were like yeah it's going to be a
light year for first party really but
was it because you had red fall you had
star field you had the new motorsport
and of course you can't everyone
everyone keeps forgetting about death
loop death loop is going to be a big
game when it releases so there are four
first party games come into your box all
in xbox game pass now it's time to throw
some confetti but of course that's not
the case right right we we have a strong
suspicion that motorsports going to be
here and so and i believe it is we know
death loop has come we know that that
was already announced it was only a year
exclusive it's probably going to be
released in september october but
there's a whole
yeah now i am i am in the same camp
of que asante where there's no way they
so abruptly
delay these games
and then have nothing
um we've been hearing and we've heard
this from you know obviously xbox two
they're very confident of course randall
thor jazz course anything they say we
got a tweet shout out to idol stall
tweet it and say it it's a yeah yeah no
no
that guy's a sleuths
whatever he's saying you say on your
show it's going up
it's it's there's a good shot that a vow
it actually could be that
that big one um not my prediction i'm
just saying that if that's the case then
that's something but i'm excited to go
into this show because of exactly what
tim said they are they have too many
bullets in the chamber
to to get a jam you know what i'm saying
they they they are going to deliver
we just don't know what they're going to
do in 2022
more than likely game pass which is in
my opinion the true exclusive
xbox
um especially if you are someone who
doesn't have money to be thrown around
and you know that hold that game pass
thought just what's that because i got
one topic right right right hold on okay
so so i mean listen i i am super stoked
this is probably the most confident xbox
show i've ever gone into and i and i say
that
because like i said i started off this
conversation with this unique position
that microsoft has painted themselves
into last year's show was a 10 out of
10.
we are all expecting they have to have
to at least meet that
right
and so that's that's that's my thoughts
on it i'll respect it i respect it let's
get the lords
attic man what's up brother 2022
a lot of stuff going on we had the two
delays
coming into this showcase how are you
feeling how confident are you
i actually
have a different feeling i feel like
last year they did a good job giving
value to services giving value to the
console because
of all the games that came into the
services but this year
as of right now
we still haven't had one real game
that's like
next [ __ ] only you know the xbox series
x
their big holiday games were delayed out
of the holiday
to my knowledge that hasn't really been
have we
is there even one first party game
supposed to come out this year besides
death luke that's been on another
platform
well we've got to see what happens with
before
i mean we're going into the event you
asked me like the state now yeah
it's just like look like i don't think
it's the end of the world but as far as
like
being an xbox owner right now it's like
i do feel like they have gener they have
failed to generate hype to buy one right
now
and i failed to generate hype to owning
one right now but you know that's that's
what this event's for you know they
they got to do that back because you
know
just the fact of delaying games out of
2022 that was uh the biggest games that
you were going for
if you look at they were so confident in
star field they they put see people keep
saying there's something wrong with my
might like you're just you're just a
little a tad louder right now but not as
bad as you were before just a tad just
turned out a tad you're good
but it we'll have to see
exactly what goes on
i'm just curious if we're able to
i just want them to
you know deliver i i do feel like
they can't go this whole year without a
game like they got to do something to
replace starfield i don't
obviously i don't think we're gonna get
nothing to replace starfield as its
whole
but they got to do something like they
got to because we're we're in a
situation where we might go
the whole
holiday with not really anything that's
that's appealing to the xbox brand no
doubt no doubt
look that's an honest assessment that's
how you feel a lot of people have echoed
that sentiment after the delay so here
we go king is readying fraud alert
lights on us and he has things he needs
to say it's okay well no it's just you
know i hear these xbox dudes and you
know a lot of guys be like oh you know
they they dropped the ball and it's been
bad news
it's doom and gloom and i'm like shut up
way way way way way hold on shut up it's
not doom and gloom cut it out it was
your first party games really delayed
out of 2022
let's break it down let's break it let's
really please biggest news activision is
going to be acquired by microsoft
right
publisher keep going i don't i don't
care what you're saying that's games
that's games from that moment it spawned
that you said and i valued your opinion
but there you go and you'll be quick to
are you going to continue talking about
how i'm talking about
i'm going to be without a king of attic
interruptions
and
i was wearing this yesterday so why are
you dressing like me
first off we all have those shirts
of course
i gotta get the blue one i love that
blue one thank you playstation
so you know
activision
that whole thing sparked conversation
and changed it put waves in it yeah ftc
jumping in yeah all types of drama going
on and then it started a buying frenzy
people started buying and doing stuff
microsoft made a chain reaction happen
very early on without any games but game
pass is still growing and dudes is
having fun but when they don't have
games inside game pass what they do go
get your game shout out to baseball who
want to play baseball you want to play
basketball i want to play mlb the show
we had a first party game made from
another studio
that's why it was great we had a first
party game already launched this year
and gameplay
i don't care what anybody says
these dudes and they was waiting
they were so petrified by the moves that
microsoft was making they was absolutely
horrified
when they said red flag
and star filled it coming up i told you
miss management over there
nobody knows exactly what they're doing
they need to get rid of phil
that still is the problem and
he's not a really is i told you king
he's not a
realist okay i got to slow you once uh
we're interrupting king so i apologize
for him i know this which i want but i
have that so kick so your perception
just to be clear
xbox was dominating in front of you you
you they had the activision thing as far
as you're concerned
it was broken
it was the cyberpunk of the situation it
didn't even sound like cyberpunk
cyberpunk was worse off
that came and that kid didn't even sell
like hotcakes so again they put out a
broken gate and they what did they
follow that probably should have got
that delayed starkville
[Music]
what did they do right after that was
the grand theresa after that yes okay
it's like on the on the bug's bunny when
he walk into one rake boom and he turn
around and walk into the other way boom
who's in trouble here
who's really in trouble here okay so so
to your point top of the year yeah xbox
was dominating as far as you concerned
that
okay hell yeah these guys
seven months ago they put out two broken
games nobody cared about all right so
and they didn't buy them they had
remember a month ago you had
face everybody's playing elder ring they
didn't care what you was doing over
there let's keep it a buck i'll give you
a buckle playstation you was playing
elder ring if you was playing xbox
you're playing elder ring so again this
game right don't don't fun on me right
now let's get this part right here
because normally in the past eldering
would have been only on playstation and
wouldn't have been on xbox but check
this out that happened good point i
don't care how it happened i don't care
why it happened but it happened and then
the npd's
oh i didn't get a chance to play gran
turismo you didn't get a chance to play
a broken game you're upset about a
broken game talk to me about this right
here right so you was playing elderly
stop front and all this is cap they want
to distract you and take you away from
the fact that the playstation show was
absolute trash why it was absolute trash
listen and i gave it an eight why
because eight of those games is
basically coming to xbox so i really
don't care right so whatever they were
doing and my pc is gonna be living
because i'm gonna be playing spiderman
let's focus on xbox
listen this is what i'm talking about
everybody's just trying to distract you
from us going into the show they want to
demoralize you guys before you get into
the show hell no don't fall for that
you got 30 something studios you walking
in there with the chief of chiefs spill
dominance maximus are really expensive
and held in charge remember the dark
days when they said this is how you
trade a game remember that don't you
never forget it we came back from the
dark days and we didn't falter we are
here right now and i'm gonna tell you
this show is gonna be absolutely
incredible um i'm gonna tell you tim can
tell you right now
every show i go in with confidence
because i see growth every year
okay
okay
okay
can i please i think king really made a
great point
and and i i didn't even think about it
but
xbox from the beginning of the year
really did set a set set the industry on
fire as far as
they were the one that made that move
where
you could you could say sony panicked or
not but tony definitely went to the
table and said
these guys are for real we gotta do
something you can question that bungee
deal maybe they spend too much money
maybe they didn't uh you know that was
up for debate but nothing came close
to what they they did with that activity
yeah that that that was zeitgeist
changing yeah how and he said and how he
got the mindshare going he's a hundred
percent correct
that's shy maybe we've got people
calling joe biden
i do you had people so shook
i do want to point out
and i think you can agree tim and king
my degree i don't know
uh
the
the way time works in the regular world
and the way time works in the gaming
industry is not the same
we
literally a week will go by and no one
will be talking about something like the
only games i've seen stand stand
above this is games like elden rain
games like the witcher like where people
talked about it for a whole month and
then never talked about it again like
this isn't one of those things where oh
they were doing good seven eight months
ago they're doing good now i'm not
saying that the brand's in like a really
bad position or anything i'm saying from
right here not
almost a year ago
from right here
i don't see them doing too hot right now
well let's get tim get his bars off
because he agrees with king well i just
i think you could talk about
this and that but if you don't have the
activision deal i think i think in in
what you're saying is is that you
accepted that they're gonna get
activision and now you just put that
aside and that's just one of the things
that they've already did but the sheer
amount of
stuff that activation could bring to the
table
i agree this is a big deal bro yeah
really you really look at the thing and
i just feel that
overall xbox we can
the numbers prove it they are they are
are doing very well they're doing much
better than last generation and
and people were not not anybody on this
thing but people were really
stomping uh they were they were grinding
for xbox to have something happen the
way it did and my problem with the way
people acted let's be honest they acted
like the games were canceled
what do you mean who did that for you
man they looking up everything looking
rosy i told dudes back before xbox
launched game pass it looked bright
i got clown
you've always been you never wavered i
know who's in charge yeah and i agree
with you and that's the way i feel i'm
confident i'm the same thing people will
say well we're just chills and that we
never okay uh you know but that's the
fact i'm chilling then
i'm just chilling you lord chill now are
you lord chill i'm not sure
[Music]
steep now and you know we can talk about
chilling all we want they're 34 studios
deep guys yeah this is not no four
studios oh for sure for sure for sure
right let me jump in because i would say
too long with this one this is supposed
to be a warm-up but um yeah look i hear
where everybody's coming from nothing's
just nothing just a moment with the
lords um look that's why i feel and for
me i'm looking at the situation a little
bit differently
because i'm gonna be real i know i was
on team
delay halo until it's actually ready to
have content shippable because the game
is absolutely amazing like boom said and
it just pisses me off because i feel
like if they were to cox advice even
though they run the company
that um and they would have had it
because i felt forza was so dominant in
2022 and king we had this discussion
internally when there was the stealth
halo drop forza to me could have rocked
but i understand halo anniversary i
understand people want it i'm not trying
to minimize that but in my mind i'm like
damn if you had 2022
you have now halo infinite fully stacked
with content and a forged mode of
cooperative and release with the
monsters that you know what i'm saying
that would have mitigated a lot but to
to tim dawg's point and king actually
set a good point i got i got nothing he
never does what i'll just say like he
made me remember something which is
it was very dominant at the start with
the activision blizzard announcement
people
some people were not were very concerned
let's just say
that the gaming sphere of mike we had a
six-hour podcast about that literally
changed gaming
right
like
it was a six hour powers i remember that
it was like right after the deal you
guys were going into it no again yeah
it's true it was it was a dominant move
let's be honest let's be honest no one
saw it coming
and king is right i gotta cause i was
about to go off i'm not doom and gloom
but king is right as far as where the
scale was typical where the meter was
going especially coming off of the last
year went down wait i got you i'm gonna
bring it full circle i got you you know
i said but what i'm saying is he's right
the pendulum was all this and then the
year before remember the metacritic like
boom said you know published a year a
lot of momentum it was oh here we go the
second half of the year right right
surprise i know i'm with you now this is
where i got a real really back in with
my boy
where where is because of like i said
the halo situation where it did then
let's be honest stalker hurt stalker
hurt big time stalking with something
nothing happens in the world stuff have
to say and it's not their fault stalker
is not that for that is an unfortunate
situation in ukraine we know what's
going on
we respect that right so you have that
act like stalker is suspended animation
we ain't got taught by stoke
faction
and then to tim's point
you know the government get involved ftc
and the statements and dudes was crying
and microsoft got that place
defending watching call of duty just the
thought of it being exclusive
made the industry go oh my god if xbox
has this game exclusive what's the scope
gonna be
it was a lot of xbox tiptoe i never see
this that's what had to come out and
make a statement like no no all right
look guys
we're good
you know
so because it's such a cat it's such a
cataclysmic deal they have to play
different
right so okay so where i'm at now is
this guy i have to i go a lotto i got to
bring it back up lord addict i'm waiting
here because
for me the reason why the delays hit
different is because
it's two exclusives at one time and it
was their only one and their only first
part that we know of at the time and the
fact that they dated starfield i myself
was wrong i thought there was no way
starfield gets delayed
with 11 11 date todd howard comes out
that's just
i think you know what makes it even
worse yeah is the fact that starfield
was their first courage engagement right
so
that that j it just threw me off and
then i'm like damn and redfield fall too
so i'm like oh my god and it just it it
it hit hard
and i'm not gonna lie that's why i would
boom i was very disappointed because i
looked at the landscape okay what is
there left that what what can what they
can they realistically do to change
what's going on and i have to be honest
not it's not doom and gloom but i wanted
i want their back to me is against the
world because i want to see how creative
they can be
based on what i know they have to deal
with i know third party like to me how
you would save it would be like a a
harry potter or a modern warfare 2.
modern warfare 2 is still contractually
from understanding underneath you know
sony and stuff like that you know what
you call it has the marketing rights for
harry potter so it puts them in a bind
again i'm with tim dole future's bright
i'm not worried it's not jumping off the
scale yeah not bad right here we just
talk about 2022 2023 i'm not even i'm
not worried about anything with the
future like to me they are like tim dawg
said the studio situation the games
that's coming i'm not even worried about
that that's where i was so that that's
my thing going i just want to quickly
get like one sentence bar about
something funny too before we do the
prediction which is and i'm
transitioning right into which is the um
state of game pass the reason why i
bring it up because this was a hot one
you know what i'm saying and this was
you know people making public statements
because of the delay people were like yo
you know what i'm saying so coming into
this showcase
i need the state of game pass for you
where you're at let's get mr boom
look um anyone that canceled game pass
because you two games that you honestly
thought were coming we all did if that's
your prerogative if that's why you
signed on for those two games
i say two things one why the heck did
you sign up so early when the game was
coming out the end of the year and two
you're just trying to look for clout
that that's that's that's the truth
sorry um game pass
look let me let me just say it like this
most of us we have a lot of people in
the chat so first of all please for the
love of joe hit that like button yes
let's let let's let's
let's tell youtube that the little guy
is mad
and you know what i'm saying and get and
get get us all into the algorithm that
we deserve to be in now
with that said
game pass is a an instant backlog
regardless of whether or not you just
found the platform like you were a
playstation dude or do that and you're
like man you know what i'm gonna get in
i'm gonna get a series s it's two it's
229. it's the best three under 300 bucks
i've spent let me find out what's going
on
any instant backlog as tall as you i got
a backlog as tall as me and i'm six feet
right
so every month game pass continues to
deliver now again i said this in the
opening xbox game pass is the
true exclusive because what that does
for you as a xbox gamer is you just go
and you press download once you're
you're 15 if you look i'll just say it
like this the state of game pass is only
getting brighter each and every month
that passes
when you have folks like sarah bond who
goes out of their way to bring in new
experiences specifically like japanese
type games jrpgs and those types of
games that we've all been asking for yes
how many people are going to download i
don't know 2 million 3 million but you
know something it's still worthy of
being in there and all and the one thing
that you have to tip your cap to uh xbox
and xbox game pass and what those folks
are doing over there is that the
the amount of genres that are available
it's a plethora of different way of
different ways to play whether you like
rts or fps or third-person shooters or
platformers you name it it is in there
now i'm going to tell you this right now
if you can't find
value at 15 for what they put in monthly
i i think you're doing the numbers wrong
i'm gonna be honest with you because
even
even in a year
that their short first party
they are still killing it within these
second and third party games each and
every month and we just got confirmation
from xbox wire that they have a ton of
big announcements coming for the
remainder of june and that's obviously
going to come with the show i i got to
tell you i think that game pass
is the best thing since sliced bread and
if you don't i hear you but i'm telling
you that 15 you spend per month cannot
be beat anywhere no can i say something
because i want to say something about
the journalist first of all take him i'm
actually friends with tay and tay and i
went back and forth on this yeah he's
not a bad guy does he have some hot
takes yeah but he's not a bad guy he i
want i want to put that out he gets a
lot of hate from things but me and him
were actually friends but it was him
it was what i didn't like about gene
park's statement which he basically got
the the twit he made a tweet and he's a
great journalist and i love him yeah
awesome what i didn't take to take out
from gene's tweet was
here he is he's like well those are the
two games says i'm about to subscribe
for now
and you know i have nothing else that i
want to play and then i see a similar
tweet two weeks before where he's like
i'm so psyched for june
super
super volleyball and and all these like
these like like super obscure games that
he's going to play
and i'm like thinking to myself i'm like
if you're into these type of games
game pass is perfect for you they have
every type of game that there is they
have tennis coming out uh that's just
coming out it looks really cool they
have everything so i just think listen i
just think what happened there was
they they were hot under the collar and
then the taco picks it up and then now
you get people telling me there's a mass
exodus on on game pass you and i both
know game pass is a service every month
they announce something every month they
have a surprise they're going to have
the biggest surprises probably coming
this and when we get into it in the
prediction show
with jude so listen i and and to boom's
point he's mentioning all that stuff
not to mention you get ea access yeah
you get all those d discounts you get
the cloud you get the cloud anywhere on
your phone on on on devices wherever you
want and you get pc
that is true
and you get rewards points yeah the
values get rewards points so i think
just like that whole stuff was just like
people wanted to write about something
they got hot under the collar and then
it just blew up let's be honest
right now game pass is still it's it's
pretty much whoever said it's xbox
exclusive
it really is it's the thing that that
when you play xbox like
this week when you hear star street
fighter 6 is now coming to xbox
dude get an xbox series s and street
fighter how could you how could a kid be
he could kid not be super excited about
that no you know what i mean no
i'm sorry that's the thing that's the
thing it's just like that's where it is
and and i just feel that uh
they just just they got the value
proposition going and i don't really
think that we it would be fair if we all
started
bouncing on that and i did feel like a
lot of people did give it a lot of
resistance including the xbox gamepad
yeah we saw xbox game fans a little
ratio action back
at a certain outlet yeah yeah
it was a big one but i did i did want to
mention it you know i'm saying i want to
because this was a big thing leading
into this showcase and what xbox was
kind of going up against i want to get
attic king real quickly on your thoughts
on the game pass value you know to
criticize criticism to subscribe
unsubscribe fair unfair and where you at
with that quickly addict and then kick
i think that when it comes to game pass
i subscribe for the potential not
necessarily a game or two
of you know randomly they're just so
like octopath traveler or something like
that in there so
those are the reasons i'm in there is
those type of games i will say this year
games that appeal to me been a little
lackluster besides you know uh uh
stronghold crusader 3. like there's been
a couple good games
door came out at the beginning
yeah uh but i will say that
there that microsoft was very adamant
about promoting
a couple years ago that they they in a
in a perfect ideal world the way they
wanted
game pass to function was three or four
games every quarter like every year uh
every a game they said the goal the goal
was like a game yeah a game of course so
i mean if you saw it on to game pass for
that kind of ideology like i guess but
like
here's my thing
i don't even really have an issue of
people unsubscribing to game pass it's
their money i'm not going to like pocket
watch them on that actually but my issue
is how are you gonna it would be
different it was after the june show and
then they're like okay they still didn't
show me nothing that apply to me right
i'm out
i just can't i can't grasp how you say
statements like that before their big
show of the year
we brought up their journalists they
know that these big shows are
like right around the corner that's the
only issue i had with that i did feel
like it was a little bit of you know
low-key protesting going on
i'd be very surprised if any of them
actually unsub the game pass you what
receipts uh yeah i don't even care about
no taser all the way he showed me he's
like 20 25 i'm laughing at him
he's like i'm like i'm like come on you
can't get out if you wanted to
don't know
people say why are you announcing
yourself like i said they wanted to
silently protest the only way you're
going to really get a point across is
i'm leaving and you know it is what it
is they have the right to do whatever
they want their social media i did feel
it was a little weird yeah uh but i
personally feel like game pass uh you
know isn't it good is it a good place i
will say first party's been a little
lackluster this year but we're only a
halfway through
uh you know microsoft is well known to
drop stuff going throughout we just had
uh sniper elite five six seven eight i
don't know which one it is uh one of
those you know they're gonna bring your
games we have the june event and i'm
sure if if ryan's right and final
fantasy vii remake
say the boss save the boss yeah so if if
that happens then you know i
right there is worth enough game pass
for june yeah it just depends on how
much
first off it's 15 to 10 dollars a month
like
do you spend more than that at
mcdonald's
i feel you will kick real quick oh yes
gas is crazy right now
shut up the king man so so wait you know
real quickly with the uh the state of
game pass the criticism to subscribe
unsubscribe that whole bit where where
are you at king you got you got the xbox
chain shining on your neck right now
what's going on we healthy over here
close the door
don't let the door hit you with the good
lord to split you
understand so you you got you got no
remorse if there's those guys in this
ain't a motel six we ain't gonna lead a
light on so you wanna sit there and play
that whole clout game right well i'm
gonna unsubscribe who cares nobody cares
do whatever you wanna do i don't even
know if you still got netflix my man oh
oh
some shows ain't there that month i'm
gonna unsubscribe somebody why are they
gonna do their hands like that i'm
subscribing
it's two slices of pizza
what are we doing over here this dude is
over here talking this crap to me it's
two slices of pizza two slices of pizza
right that's that's that's the 15 for
your game you ain't got money for two
slices
are you pocket watching the people oh
absolutely pocky watching it's this is
the greatest show on earth right now
right now ringling brothers is gone and
game pass is taking its place right it's
the greatest show on earth and you guys
just talking about you ain't got two
pizzas to get into you know what the
hell is wrong with you guys yeah i can't
even i listen you you guys is really
you're making me upset here you just
showed me how feeble you actually are
two games two games
two games got delayed they said it's
coming later not never true but later
good points you're behind i think i'm
gonna unsubscribe now give me back the
value i gave you
you can't come at the house and
repossess all the games let me tell you
something give me back my life
and that's what's gonna happen you think
all that stuff you download is gonna
still be there you're gonna go in there
and you're gonna you know try to play
your favorite game what happened you
forgot it was all game passing you
downloaded it it was an x for you
because your money wasn't right because
you didn't have enough for two teams
you cannot repossess
that was game pack this is the perk for
gamepad this is what they're afraid of
look at that game that you had so much
fun with i had so much fun with this
game and it was in game pass oh i can't
pay this month and you went to log on
and said
so as soon as you're behind sit there
and say i'm not going to pay for my game
pass because i you know i don't like
what they did with starfire you don't
even know what starfield is shut up
oh man i was i really wanted to play red
four what is it
um i i think it's just strictly like
hype level
yeah listen like imagine imagine if
if if you if you're i'm
imagine if your team gets in the
superman like we delaying it two months
people gonna beat now people but people
gonna be upset
it's acting like they gonna die tomorrow
okay i can see if you you know
something was happening and you ain't
gonna make it to next year i can see you
be like man i really wanted to play
redford really
really
you got all the impressive matters
listen the game is gonna come out you're
gonna have a good time it's not it's
just delayed all y'all was on cyberpunk
head for launch and broken factual and
and when 600 percent
went on when the patch came out and it
was the next generation patch that was
there like i told you that's when i
purchased i'm part of that 600 percent
because i said i value my money right so
if they put out red fall and it's broken
you say i'ma wait for it to be finished
and because of you it came out early so
sit there and let it get fixed and when
it's fixed you get it it's yo you don't
get this ain't this is how the buffet
works bro this is how the buffet works
sometimes it ain't no chicken there you
got to eat steak or eat your steak the
chicken is coming it's cooking inside
the kitchen you want to get salmonella
poison no
[Laughter]
you protected us
we got to look at it from this
standpoint too these are journalists
that probably get these games
review codes and stuff do they even
really need game pass at that time like
well look let me jump right because
again we stayed too long
it was fun i had to let you get your
ball your boss premium was premium one
but you know to king's point you know
for me and i said this or define and do
shout out to maddie we'll be pulling up
so is that you know for me i don't go on
twitter in public and be like i'm
breaking up with my girlfriend
like that's just not how i'm cut to be
if you're unsatisfied and you have every
right if you're on satisfied then you do
what you got to do right that's for you
but there are still a lot of people and
tim donald can attest to this that still
find great value in the service you know
i'm saying that are still playing having
a ball and for me personally
it was still solid well i say last year
was better yes or up to this point but
right now i'm playing mlb the show i'm
playing track to yomi i'm playing
crusader kings i'm playing you know
iodine chronicle mass effect trilogy
jumped in there there was still games
for me that i'm like yo this is a solid
year so i didn't unders to me it was
just weird to me to see all this public
announcement again i'm not trying to
disrespect anyone who loves aaa games
and if that's the only type of game you
like then okay yes maybe for you right
now it's a disappointment i just thought
it was interesting that i saw people and
there's no personal shot at anybody you
know saw people say that they gonna
public unsubscribe but look the value is
there in my opinion it's still one of
the best values in gaming and it's up to
them though to facilitate the service
but that's what i got on that now let's
get to this main event you know cuz
y'all know what we're here for i know
yeah we're so obviously i could say it's
classic singing
look this is the big one this is the big
one
the xbox and bethesda prediction series
time
sunday june 12th appropriately on the
launch day king appropriately at one p.m
eastern it wouldn't be right if it
wasn't
you don't say do it on slot and the
lawyers will definitely live streaming
but we got to talk right now we got to
get to those spicy
predictions what you're thinking mic
drop moments you know what i'm saying
and all that good stuff and then i also
want a little more spice to it because
attic makes me laugh when he does this
also with besides the predictions
besides the bike drop i need
what you need to start the show
and what you need to end the show so
let's get started let's get tim dog
going because boom i know you cooking
boom i know you cook i want you but i
gotta save i gotta make the audience
wait for it let me simmer let you simmer
because i know you cooking i already
know you are the king of this
but i gotta let the og go first all
right all right let's go so
okay so i'm going to give you what i
think they're going to start with end
with
uh some of the things that um
uh
uh that i think is going to happen now
let's go i can tell you one thing
the gameplay stuff
that's that's been that's true the the
that they're gonna show a lot of
gameplay that's that's from what very
good sources there's gonna be
more gameplay than you've probably we've
seen in a long time um and uh that could
be because of the mandate supposedly
somebody said last year
last year the big thing was cgi we want
to see you play obviously so we're now
at that point where we're going to do
that so i do think that they're going to
start the show with what do i think that
they're going to start the show with
now i don't think
that
let's just do this what did they start
the show with last year i think it's
going to be very similar
to what they did last year okay um i
think that uh the way bethesda
influenced them
was that they want to have these shows
with no down times so if you remember
the old uh 360 shows
everything would be going great and then
they would have some guy dancing on the
thing or justin bieber
and we're all like what's up
and those are the things that they want
to avoid so we're not going to have
personalities you know what it seems oh
i shouldn't rush it
sorry okay it's true but they they want
to have that flow okay and we all know
what that flow is yes that means that we
don't have a point where we're like
scratching our heads during the show
yeah this thing sucks or
you know whatever or stop start venting
on twitter um or we see something really
strange like unsubscribed
back on them yeah to bring why starfield
team why
because
it's what we've been waiting for it's
the biggest thing that they have
and i think that they're gonna have
gameplay and i think that that's huge
now if we all remember
bethesda where they showed fallout
that's how they started it i believe
that's what the show would fall out and
you could always remember he was in that
barren land and he was running around in
that blue suit and everyone started
going crazy i think we're gonna have a
similar uh experience like that
um then i do think uh we are going to
see game play
for
uh
i think they're gonna start hot and
heavy so
i think they're gonna do starfield then
i think that they're going to uh
transition into
forza and they're going to announce
forza they're going to show game play
okay and then and then they're going to
announce forza
and and people flaw through any anybody
reading this this is just pure sure it's
too late sloth gotcha tim dawg
of xbox confirmed we're going up live on
all the major websites you're hurting
here first thank you
so i do think they're gonna have four
fours of gameplay and i think they're
gonna show it
um
and that's gonna be like something they
said often that's how the show is gonna
start you're gonna get that type of
momentum you're gonna get gameplay now i
talked to attic about this i think that
they're gonna show gameplay
through at least four games
so let's just say
uh the third game is red fall and they
show a full full full game
game uh game play so now you have forza
star field red fall right now we're all
like jumping around then i think they'll
transition into game pass
and they'll talk about uh
will they show stalker i don't know i
mean i heard i i heard stalker uh
uh god bless them i heard that they are
actually back to development yes
you know and uh
it takes four weeks to make a game play
supposedly it makes four weeks to do a
demo
so that's all hands on deck so i don't
know if you're gonna see game play but i
think you might see stalker you might
get a tease on stalker
atomic heart
um and then they will transition into
uh
which is uh rand's uh predictions which
was both mine and rants
final fantasy 7
um and uh that's gonna hit game pass
yeah so i think that's a way for them
you know i really don't like you tim
right
i really don't think he's about to cook
king's about to cook
he took that he stole like he stole that
from him
you could search my tweets i've been
talking about that oh we got the
receipts get it
it's a logical thing we all know we want
final fantasy vii we want it to be on
game pass i i it's possible it might not
thank you even listen even if it doesn't
hit game pass it's a very big gap but
hold on rand outdoor insider is in the
chat said game pass
and he said at the show shadow shadow
listen man
that that makes me confident i love you
red is that ryan's saying that let me
tell you confidence confidence so if
they shadow drop that man that's huge
hey ran i'll do a bend the knee with you
if they shut it down
that is the most detailed prediction
we've seen they did say they have some
big announcements for june at the show
and that's a big one
square square came out
no xbox wire did oh okay gotcha okay but
also also square did say that they're
going to have an update and this was
what prompted me to final fantasy 7
let's go uh earlier in the month
they they said that they're gonna have
an update for final fantasy vii and as
you know there's been a little hint
uh the exclusivity uh for persona five
oh tim
uh persona 5 and final fantasy 7 came
off uh the the the playstation only on
on the unplugged
so
in my opinion
i think that uh that that's they're
gonna be their way to transition wow
uh i don't know if you're gonna get
persona five in game pass okay i do
think it's so very possible that you're
gonna get it as long as it comes i guess
solves these i don't know final fantasy
7 i think is going to be a uh
a thank you uh for um
for for that and um yeah then then then
after that it gets murky like now now we
got four things that's pretty solid
really good announcements
um
is about gonna show gameplay
yes
i'm gonna say yes i i think i think
about it's gonna show game play
and i think uh
it is possible they might end the show
with with with with the valve
gonna say that yeah
we need to shut
[Music]
so now now we have pretty much by the
baselines of what i think is going to
happen now i always say you have a good
show
when you have a surprise yes preaching
that's the thing so
i think it's 50 50 we get a surprise
okay i'm not going to give a strong
indicator so i want to say 50 50 we get
a surprise announcement you don't have
to give us the strong indicator tim just
tell us the game no no
um no surprise listen surprise could be
anything surprise could be even a studio
who knows
did you say acquisition
because i'm not actually if you didn't
know kim
get ready tim i i got to interrupt you
but if you don't know on twitter i am
lord acquisition they're very angry with
me when i say that that would actually
excite people because what games you
know of course but i did say that would
be a nice
little thing something there is an
acquisition they're they're buying the
iron boards yeah yeah
i guess that's true
so so i'll give him that and then the
other big question is are we going to
see
uh hellblade
so are we going to see hellblade i think
now let's let's get this out of the way
fable out we're going to see nothing on
facebook
all right now get him out of
the state of uh the k3 out oh no on
their labs okay okay um
and then i think you're gonna see the
pentium game that everyone the project
uh if maya close to me my heart i'm
gonna uh
say that they're gonna have maybe show
the wu-tang
oh don't give me [ __ ] you give me
projects charlene yeah yeah
and um
i think that that's going to be pretty
much just the show and i do think that
they might
tease
uh
uh
2021 i i do i heard that they wanted to
have
two shows this year
um they're gonna be at gamescom but it's
not gonna be like probably what you
think it's gonna be
um
if infinite show that he didn't have a
show listen if activision deal was going
to close they'd have 100 of the deal
because i do think that when activision
closes that's going to have its own show
too
kind of like where bethesda had with
that round table yes but yeah honestly i
feel that that's
the bulk of my predictions
um i think you're gonna see game play on
four play four games okay um you're
gonna get some definite game game pass
announcements they're gonna show things
like uh you know uh
the dust fall game the summerset there's
a lot of there's a lot of uh games that
are coming out for the indies that are
looking strong
and i think that you might actually you
not really people care but you'll see
gameplay and stuff like that on that end
but um i'm thinking uh yeah a start uh
uh starfield
and avowed final fantasy vii the big
uh
yeah so that's
you know my big thing is is that i'd be
happy if we didn't get
a couple of those things okay but if we
get that surprise the biggest thing for
me what's the biggest one for a show
let's go
get a surprise now the surprise can be
anything though i i don't want to give
you a surprise is what we're not
thinking of so i'm not going to say it's
going to be this but let's get along the
lines of
um uh
you know uh one of these games uh what's
that the uh you know they get a game
past day one or uh okay for uh for uh
what's that game the the the superhero
got them superhero
so something like that or something of
an acquisition anything that can give
you a surprise to me if you get a 10 to
10 show you got to have that surprise
it hits us from left field yes so like
wow i didn't see that coming oh but
overall i think we're gonna have a
really good show with their confidence i
think that they're almost pretty much
done with the show they are still
actively
uh dabbling in it i know that they were
working together a week ago and um
you know they they they're smart enough
to
you know if something falls in the at
the at the 11th hour to say hey let's
freaking
get something scratch something up and
just get this announced so uh you'll see
phil talk you'll see sarah talk you
might see aaron talk okay um
you know you'll see uh the heinz talk um
and bethesda here a surprise i'll give
you oh let's go let's get across let's
go wolfenstein three oh next year all
right now you gotta go
all right now you guys
take it everybody
yo didn't i just say that to you uh the
other day boom
[Music]
xbox guys here so and for me to go first
i know it's kind of okay because
you get that you get that you avoided
everybody's card
[Laughter]
but let's be honest if they have four
games with game play yeah that's
satisfying this is the people say oh
this sucks the sex [ __ ] i'm
cancelling and i'm burning my ass back
i'm burning is my here's my receipt
but uh you know waiting for these
playstation dudes to put a chainsaw to
their playstation
i think boys please cut your train so
your playstation
to close
i think that um
uh we're gonna be happy i think that
they they really uh set us up for
for for this when they disappointed us
with the the uh last month because it
really was a it was tough a lot of
people it was so i think a big bounce
back moment and uh hopefully they they
do what they're supposed to do uh like i
said this isn't like a couple of years
ago where they really couldn't make up
anything oh i got one other thing oh
let's go golden eye uh
game pass as well that's coming as well
what come on
okay listen lg set it off we got to get
the building we got to get the
temperature up there's only there's only
there's one i mean tim took the
temperature up he did but there's one
man and when it comes to predictions
when it comes to giving you goosebumps
no one does it better than mr bull stick
xl i have to give my brother that he
gets me hyped thank you sir all the time
so boom i know you're cooking this is a
big one so you know the format what are
you looking for what would be a mic drop
moment what do you want to start what do
you want to end this is june 12th this
is the big stage backs against the wall
somewhat some may say
delays some may say king stop shaking
your head
boom i'm gonna shut up and you take us
through where we got to go well listen
what what did we talk about in the
opening of the show 2022 right like what
what are they bringing to 2022 i love
what tim had to say but i'm gonna tell
you what i'm doing if i'm big papa phil
and i'm setting up this show
i open up with a vowed oh
you just going you can't just i'm and i
tell you what not only do i show you
game play i say it's coming 11 11 22.
you doing the met
this year
obsidian comes in remember listen
obsidian was purchased because they were
working on this game right now and they
said
let boom go let boom go stop stop
listen they've been working on it before
2018 from what we understand right we're
now in 2022 no one puts a game better
together faster than obsidian they run a
tight ship number one so they come out
and they say okay
avowed gameplay guess what folks you
getting it on eleven eleven twenty two
we are taking star fields place
the christmas tree we got okay
right
so so then the rest of the show listen i
think middle of the show you get your
star field you get your right you get
your red floor there's no doubt about
they're going to show we're getting
gameplan of the rising sun oh arriving
in a big way
that's right that's right we're going
you're going to see final fantasy 7
guess what download it right now
with the integrate
yeah with integrate everything full the
full bells and whistles go download it
right now persona 5 royale oh
boom get in there there you go you're
getting all that
i think that we actually get a chance to
see compulsions game you get game play
for compulsions game night
what is that supposed to be that's
supposed to be uncharted meets bioshock
in a fantasy section right so that
that's a big one um i i think that
and i agree with tim i don't think we
see fable unfortunately tom and now
there's no rush for that we know what's
coming let them work on let them do what
they got
[Music]
right no no seriously uh and i i think
we get motorsport gameplay i think
that's that's a solid point that is
coming this year i think that comes out
in october they make that announcement
big boy um i think that we are going to
see
some third-party announcements
uh to be honest with you i i definitely
see some third-party announcements and
you know one of the bigger ones that i
really want to see and i got a shout out
hip hop gamer
i'm on his train um i think that not
only do we get a chance to see splinter
cell remake but they announced that
right along with hey ubisoft plus in
game pass no extra charge
we're not charging you you hitting them
with the one two hitting them with the
splinter cell the lights and the ubisoft
plus ubisoft plus yeah and guess what
right in there i wasn't agreeing with
slova but now we definitely probably
need to get
no let listen there's no one i got one
one last big one you're not even
finished
i am on team
team
acquisition
so
gentlemen phil the gentleman gamer yes
yes that's how you close out this is how
this is how you close out the show
that's how i close up the show right
phil comes out and he says listen i want
to thank everybody for coming and
checking out what what we put out there
hopefully you had a great show and we've
been listening to you we know that first
part is important we know that we have
legendary classic ip you want to see
come back
and you know what we've heard you want
just the one more so i'm going to
deliver it for you
let me introduce a good friend of mine
and boone is going to what we're doing
and ed boone's going to say thank you so
much phil it was great to be a part of
the xbox uh bethesda showcase i'd like
to announce to everybody that
netherrealm studios has now become first
party and we have joined a great
studio
and he's gonna say listen we've been
working secretly with uh you know with
microsoft for the last six months we're
not ready to show the game
that we're working on look at what
but
i'm gonna play something for you and it
sounds like this
wait
they're going to be the developer
shut the lights black and if the show is
going to end and they admit they're
going to be announced let's get started
like
they're going to announce to the world
that their team at netherrealm is
rebooting
killer and stuff oh my god put your name
in here together
folks watch this
oh it's over
well
hold on i'm not going to let you just
casually walk past that before we pass
it off which part
he said
it's already but but bro he said it that
ball come out phil go break boom out
netherrealm in the building potentially
i would i would love that i would like
oh my let me tell you right now y'all in
there slandering if any one of these
have y'all i want
y'all boom knees i'm telling y'all right
now if any one of them happen i'm coming
for you i got the receipts y'all you're
here
here's the thing you know obviously
hoglar good friend of this community
great friend of this program and myself
he came out and he said yeah they could
pick up a studio or two and you know
what i where
my heart's still broken over crystal
deep like
that was the one
but if there's somebody embrace them
if there is one
studio
that you buy that has in it's in the
contract if you ever listen to ed boon
talk where he goes mortal kombat goes
and we know that wb games wants to shed
some weight and that's a big one yes and
listen microsoft if if they can pull it
off
with that tim is it a multi-player
that's my question yes that's the
question no no it would stay multiplied
mortal kombat can stay multiplied
yeah that's not a problem because
obviously you know you populate first of
all fighting games the genre is is a bit
of a niche thing so you want you want to
populate it so yeah mortal kombat 12
yeah that that comes to pc that comes
that comes the playstation no no first
no must there
but he just said in an interview
that they're working on something that
is new to the studio that they've never
done before and if i i have to stop
because if i say anymore i'm gonna get
in trouble
and that came from ed himself
and like i said
if you want to stop the internet in its
tracks
phil introduces him he announces just
like tim of legend did with double fine
and when he remember we were there he
came out and he said yeah we're part of
xbox game studios now we've been
acquired ed boon comes out
just he's wearing another one t-shirt
killer instinct he just went netherrealm
studios and he announces hey we have
officially joined xbox game studios
and you know what i can't show you what
we're working on because we're not ready
for showing but i'm going to play
something for you and it's going to go
just like this
boom there you go ultra combo breaker
wow that's definitely you know what boom
if yours happened i'd be so happy but
you got you got me all nervous i got
listen the internet would break
it would so so it would be one of those
show-stopping moments that again we've
been it would be the best show that'll
be the best show ever for me yeah
and i see y'all y'all i got you all in
4k in that chat king and attic i got
your face is recorded
oh
oh we get the option
okay
we heard it happen
so look we got
the best spot
yes royalty
a legend in the game been doing it a
long time
salute to coming through kid we won't be
right we had to get you apologies we got
your last minute we supposed to have you
earlier that's all i do
i take the slings for attic it was my
fault
so i'll be look me looking black these
days
so i've got a tag back from vr a little
darker but look
kid we got you in here man we need to
know where you at i need your
predictions
i need a mic drop and i need for kids
i'm very curious about this with you
cause you're very structured with how
you think with xbox what do you need to
start the show also and end this show to
showcase
you gotta start strong and you have to
finish strong um but
you know
they also still got to show you know
bethesda is a part of this as much as
xbox so they're gonna have a big
presence some way and the other and i
expect them to have the longest demos so
this is what they're gonna do they're
gonna start off the show reverse of what
they did last year they opened the show
with red fall gameplay oh man
so we're going to stay forever we're
going to put the little dude first
a good awesome
uh
co-op experience a lot of dialogue a lot
of finishing moves being showed off a
lot specialty moves showing off the
game's going to look tremendous it's
going to look very good
um
graphical fidelity it is yup
and
they're going to finish off
that gameplay demo
with a uh
april
oh
april now i'm gonna give you the date we
give it a date they're gonna finish it
why did it take you so long to find that
day you read the email
don't worry about where he got the
information
let's get to it
so you talking you talking a nice little
spring
release
red fall look super continue i like this
keep going going all right
[Music]
too much nori we're gonna get uh
contraband's gonna show up yeah oh my oh
with some chaotic
this is going to be gameplay the closest
thing we can touch okay because i got
january 24th oh
okay okay but you know what he's out
here
wow i think that's where we live
yeah okay
like boom
[Music]
i blame tim dope
tim came out took everybody's answer so
dude
so boom went the next level and we
really
went
this is unprecedented this is the first
in prediction series history like his
spoof is on his square
this is saying this right now
it's smooth gets idiot he's released
i'm giving you powerball numbers
tomorrow
i want to go i want to retire you know
until next year how to get rich yes yes
all right so continue but we're
interrupted like there's greatness being
talked about the best spot
by facebook you don't want to work for
it listen i need this to continue we got
we got the red for we got the contraband
now with the date we're talking january
top okay continue sir all right let's go
i think um obviously
um
playground is going to show up with
their latest forza horizon expansion yes
um i'm not exactly sure because they
they surprise me every time they do an
expansion but that's going to be taking
place literally their expansion is going
to come out in august with cookies and
cream
then turn 10 is going to take the range
from playground back-to-back show us
some forza motorsport eight okay if
they're gonna confirm that release date
is october 4th oh my god
[Applause]
i like that one i think that's strong
i like that one
i like that one
he's definitely looked on the calendar
yeah october it makes sense though
october makes sense i think
it's a tuesday it's a tuesday look he
ain't that far off with this one
kid i'm with you on this great kid um i
think um
i know this is i'm just shooting it out
here because people have been saying oh
no you're just shooting it out here
shut up y'all y'all not believe it
i
[Music]
um i got a couple they're going to give
us uh our
uh the japanese crowd is going to have a
section okay okay in that section
we will get
persona 5 for first under 5 strikers and
persona 4 golden yeah
[Music]
that's going to be the second half of
xbox sega relationship because the first
half was the yakuzas and now they're
going to be working on
i like this tip
i like this thing he got you all
kids move making uh iron man making up
an entire new element look bad right now
listen he's freaky he's he's spitting
guy bro continue and then we're gonna
sit and then
let the man get his balls off
um somebody from xbox is going to be a
regular t-shirt
wait they're going to come out with the
iop listener
i got to set this up he said i i don't
know it's not clear
i see somebody walking through the crowd
at the show wearing a little shirt
yo hey i got it y'all messed it up
there's a reason you don't see cock's
background because he really ain't out
of the face
like that look everybody shut up
close your eyes and let kids move let it
take us where this place is who's coming
out and what's the shirt who's walking
out there it's going to be does he have
on chris it's going to be shut up
it's going to be a modern warfare 2
t-shirt
but in fine print which we're going to
have to all zoom it's going to say game
pass day one oh my god oh my god okay
and they have to do that because they
can't legally
talk about it but they're gonna have a
little shirt
i gotta shut you down
[Laughter]
is going to come out kate right in the
coalition okay
like this i like this first
qualification we're going to confirm you
know it's going to be a little like uh
you know little scissor reel of the
marcus phoenix collection we're going to
see it and with the ray tracing the
loomis is running on rolling japan
they're going to say
uh you know they're going to release the
marcus phoenix collection on november
8th
22.
she and that's that collection is going
to lead us they was like oh but let's
show you what we've really been working
on and we're going to reveal their next
year's game which i don't know what it
is oh so we get it we get it oh so we
get you guys
so you got the gizz collection
don't go that far listen shut up
and the new ip so a potential new ip oh
i like this continue was it holding a
teddy ruxpin continue
dude there's more
is there weight there's more let's go
come on take me there uh
our boy uh what's his name pete hines
who's not coming out on the stage that's
the better question he'll be there
his mouth continues he's gonna give us
some you know some you know updates some
game pass updates that's where he's
going to be able to let us know that
death luke will be launching on xbox uh
game pass
in september reads the book um
he's also going to announce the
partnership that him that he invited
bethesda in the next i'll have for the
fallout remasters oh
so okay that now now you're a little bit
more you know what something one thing
i'd like to add about that it's actually
i was thinking oh god we're adding more
to this no no no no i do think i told
you this on the phone when we're talking
about it
i think it would be really cool and i
think i heard that uh death death loop
is one of the um test subjects for fsr
and uh for the super resolution it's a
great game i i think it'd be really cool
if they could say hey
uh you're going to get death loop and
you're going to see it running on
uh our you know uh
fsr and then they show it like running
on yes like 1080p
you know what i mean so uh that that is
a possibility they are i know that they
are in uh they are using that as a
testbed for ssr
okay okay continue
i do
believe that
hey valdes is going to be at the show
we're going to get gameplay there yeah
and that's a quarter that's a quarter 3
20 23 game
quarter
three um
we will also get
a surprise
the surprise is gonna be indian i think
so the now we're just surprised this is
the surprise now these surprises indiana
jones uh okay and the jones
todd gameplay gonna drink some stuff
okay does he have the leather jacket he
had the leather jacket let's go oh man
he's gonna he's gonna have the billy
jeans
is he coming in on a skateboard
billy gene let's go he's gonna come in
with the xbox series x controller uh-oh
he's like and now we bring you oh
starkville wow okay
he's gonna own
up to 12 minutes
jacket with a michael jackson controller
yeah listen
he's the king of that level though kiss
moves oh he's the king of that leather
jacket so he go so we're gonna save star
feel for that
we'll close out the show with
and the gameplay release date will be 3
3 23.
they go give another day
323 however what they gonna say they
still gonna promise us that eleven
eleven because we're gonna be playing
the beta on eleven eleven oh so that
they're gonna make up one okay okay
okay they say they say wait a lot of you
you still getting 11 11.
okay you go get the beta you're gonna
get the beta and then three three
twenty three
i don't know
[Laughter]
sloth i want these up you've been
tweeting everybody else i don't see the
ilp love i need the boom joints i need
to kiss move i want y'all to say kid
smooth insider a boomstick excel inside
i want the tweets i want the clown you
know what i i want i want to ask the
chat too yes all right let's say
kids with boom who's is more likely to
happen that's what i wanted
who's is more likely to happen kid
smooth for one
boom for two and i got all of y'all in
4k laughing and if any one of these come
true i'm screenshotting and we putting
it up
[Laughter]
but i'm being messy and that's what we
need
with so much enthusiasm now so look they
got the tools they got okay okay so
let's get into it the lords you know
what i'm saying we gotta do we do
attic
where you at
what do you need
spicy mic drop and your favorite i love
that you created this
what does attic need to start the show
what does attic need to finish this is
important to you i know
i think they're gonna play it safe and
start out with floriza oh
i don't think they would do any like car
in the middle of the stage or anything
like that but
i don't think it's going to be long
is going to drive a car
i think i think they're going to do that
then i think they're going to go into
red fall
i think that's going to be gay
i think this could be gameplay but not
like an excessive amount like a montage
of gameplay not like no one playing the
game like the game on the stage
uh then i think that they're going to
announce like some game pass games
uh i do think final fantasy 7 will make
an appearance and here's my
here's my boom and kiss food mode oh oh
let's go let's add to the fire i think i
think
let's go square enix is gonna come on
the stage
let's go
can you guys smoke
whatever the hell tim said addict was
coming with this engine
xbox dude he's telling me to temper my
ex
dude y'all running around with your head
down beating up with the muckety mucks
with the what
you might your arm might turn into mr
fantastic and you grab it so like you
can easily
start you gotta name it
the the the tim effect it's like the
butterfly thing he's looking like this
moment he's a ripple that started this
this whole magnet
listen so so i feel like score is gonna
pop up i don't know who it's going to be
oh god he's all he's getting spooked
i can see it but i don't know his face
hold on let me try to hold me down call
me down
hold up he said he's weird
hold up
and they're like
they they show a trailer for final
fantasy 7 remake and we think it's all
good they're going to gay past and then
like we got one more then they show you
final fantasy vii remake part two and a
trailer too and it's coming to xbox one
mike can talk about the marketing right
oh they got the money oh my god they
went for the juggernaut for the jungle
okay okay okay
if there is some acquisition i don't
think it's going to be anything big i
think they might
uh once contraband comes out if it is at
the show they might announce they bought
uh
acquisition load acquisition likes this
yeah i don't think it's going to be
anything big yeah that's right
yeah
i would personally
like for them to end the show with
buying sega and they show them persona
6. oh
but that's just me i know that's not
gonna happen but i i think it's for the
most part what i like about this is even
though his is his arm stretchy his boob
and kids moves was
i could see the majority of them being
realistic like you know obviously not to
that point like there's some things they
said i don't see happening but i could
see
normally every year
we come into this and we there's like
three options really for the beginning
i have no idea what they're gonna open
and close this thing away wow
part of me thinks it's a vow part of me
thinks it's it's red fall part of me
thinks it's forza and what i like is it
could be any of that yeah that's true
i think i i think you are going to see
golden eye here at some point i mean
someone literally just leaked the
achievement list of golden eye yeah so i
i do think you're going to see that here
i think they're going to end it with
compulsions gang
i think i think they're going to end it
with something new i love that i love
that that's that's fire all right king
realm's been patient you've been
shaking your head
surprisingly a lot of times
you know
i got to know watch him be all of ours
combined i just want to know why
everybody's so disillusioned
but can't you you are the lord you are
the prophet
it's not i'm okay it's not temporary
expectations you're temporary i'm gonna
tell you this i'm gonna tell you this
let me tell you this
first of all microsoft and i'm gonna
look at your eye okay
because um
we had a third-party show
yeah you showed me games that i was
supposed to be playing on my series x in
my series okay okay
i haven't seen exxonmocky not yet
actually i've been waiting for that i
have not saw bright memory influence yes
wait for that oh my man factual it's a
lot of games that you've shown
and it hasn't reached my home that is
correct so i don't give a dag about
anything new you're trying to do until
you can give me
two days later
what you
got give me what you promised
all right now i i don't care about
anything else right now so when
everybody's talking about that red fall
i was like yeah but i saw gameplay of
exo machina yeah they look crazy
royal let's go
where where's the stuff that yeah all
right so first of all complete your damn
task cause obviously you don't know the
excitement you show something you bring
it in you present it you got homework
you're missing your homework it did not
show up and don't tell me the dog ate it
again microsoft i'm sick and tired of it
give me i don't care you showed it right
fair you promised me right fair i paid
my 500
and i went out there and brought an army
of little men
[Laughter]
microsoft need to get that together the
show starts off with forza
all right it starts off you hear the
call
but
it's a car out there and it looks real
just like they did with what you're
gonna call it with forza horizon
and the car drives off and it's actually
the game oh game looks absolutely
amazing
there's ray tracing in the game
all right and why you racing not in a
separate photo mode
and they don't got hits from the 80s
where you playing pat benatar while
you're sliding down the block you don't
got a car since 97. anyway so they said
they're going to send the shots to us
that
but that that's what they're gonna show
they're gonna open and get the the the
event off with that
i think that's a big ticket item
i think it's go go big go home you're
gonna show uh halo
oh halo back to the paris
uh halo uh uh extra story campaign oh
let's go to the story the endless
right um they're gonna show these merry
channels
everybody's walking past 343 like they
some jokes this is stuff that's on the
slate this is stuff that has to come out
okay you know so this stuff is coming
out
um
let's go
now everybody keeps talking about evolve
and i keep
thinking
about outer worlds too
for some now we're in the reaching zone
but for some reason
i believe that they're going to talk
some something about outer worlds too oh
and look at the point and the golden eye
aspect yeah yeah this is where the audio
cues is going to come in this is when
bethesda theatrics is going to kick in
you're going to hear
them
and that's when they talk about
goldeneye and all that great stuff
but then you're gonna hear
the indiana jones song okay oh [ __ ]
all
right
there's more you're going to hear
oh
then you're going to see the cascade and
you're going to see a trailer for
indiana jones
with actual gameplay with him traversing
the land whoever that person may be if
it's old indiana jones young and indiana
jones i really don't know
well phil
right
so all right so as we're moving in y'all
get uh you know the starfield stuff
you'll get the bethesda stuff you get
the wolfenstein stuff that's great you
know um did you get final fantasy
can't no um going to go to game pass
cause that exclusive stuff is over and
somebody said no it's going to pc no
fool it's going to xbox you're going to
game pass
all right so you gatekeeped it long
enough and now the game is going there
i'm pretty sure at some point in time
sony's going to announce the next part
going to them it doesn't agree
so it that's that's going to happen
i think that that'll solve for the blow
too yeah
100 i think that's why they would be
considerate so is because they're gonna
announce uh
like you said they're gonna announce it
the second part for sony it's probably
gonna be the same [ __ ] you know they
don't announce it but
we'll know in the that that it's it's
gonna be the same deal because we got
this one and the swap for the blower a
little exactly so that i want to be in
game pass and they'd be like shut up
play it yo you ain't missing out on that
yeah
and you have all the the dlc and
everything
fantastic okay right but they closed the
show yes let's get it
on call of duty
oh we ahead of the fans ahead of the
face
they
call
they close the show
with call of duty not war zones my man
that's what y'all looking for the
marketing rights
nah they closed the show on call of duty
oh call of duty wasn't it uh sony's
third party show what was that he wasn't
on the list all right and on the 8th
there will be a show um
but then that means it's been shown
already it's been in the wild and
microsoft is going to end just
reaffirming
that commitment to something like that
that'd be a big deal
that would be a big deal even if it's
just
in namesake
you know why you know why tim i'm saying
that
because the last time they end on um
another person's iep
in the ag's field
you were pissed yeah yeah yeah but he
calmed me down really quickly it's been
i remember i was right there yeah
so you came right up to them right right
i think midnight got it on on clip did
you see
it that's one thing i love i love about
the love about king and everyone you
kept the real that that was a weird that
2017 one people were a little scratching
their heads yeah like i didn't
understand it
but once you tell me that it's business
there's no bigger business than
activision
there's no bigger business than than
stomping your foot on the competition
next that is scared to come out the door
it came out the door half-heartedly this
week with with stuff that was multiple
was for everybody else these are the
only dudes that's keeping the light on
like a motel 6 and giving fan service
and showing a show normally where e3 is
supposed to be they keeping that good
feeling going you understand this is
they keeping the furry dice up inside
the the
on their hands they're keeping
everything fresh
let's go all right with the tree
he's got vinyl baby like you said and
and you've always been good at this
you said the thing that really caught me
when we were talking earlier about the
state of xbox and kind of making me
realize
listen we all talked about activision ad
nauseum since the beginning of the year
and probably even got sick of it because
every day we were talking about feds and
ftc and whole gloves making videos it's
going crazy
but the bottom line is is that the the
what you talk about when you talk about
size and and and the the the needle
moving
aspect of that it really is
if they close the show just to say call
of duty and just say hey we got
marketing deals
that'd be a huge deal it really would
it'll piss people off
they'll piss the haters off
but it would be a good thing i think
that that would just kind of like
reaffirm it
um
and to be honest uh i there were times
where i thought the deal wouldn't go
through but i honestly feel like they're
gonna get this one
and and if they if they like i said if
they
get this activision deal and we're
talking about it next year next year's
show
um you know like because
it's possible that they
uh it's gonna be a right right around
they'll probably have their own show
whatever we'll probably be doing a
special show but
that's just an absolute huge deal by
xbox 68 billion dollars it's what we all
asked for though we wanted them to make
that move absolutely and they did it
and i think that that's why like we're
here right now we we discuss what we
discussed
they definitely did start the year with
that was a
you know
an epic move oh yeah oh still in the
process and and uh if they could dabble
and dip it
and try to you know i mean they
shouldn't be able to not talk about it
if they could get a marketing deal i
think they'd be if the marketing deal
was up they could
they could they could market it on on
the on the show there's nothing wrong
with that because they could have done
that either way if they didn't acquire
them right yeah yeah
no no i'm with you man i think that that
less king he do it
listen like my stuff is timid and mild
compared to
bro but we're gonna let you slide past
activision call of duty at the end just
to let them know
that's always what you do to put first
of all you're paying yourself i don't
care how much money you send them to
have that game on your stage yeah you
get it back in september like it don't
matter check claire check claire back
over here
so i don't care how much money i got to
pay to get something ripped out the
hands of the enemy that's acting like
they got stuff popping don't have stuff
popping just show them where the boot
lies this is the reason why the size 15s
is under your bed this is what it is
when you came back from work and was
like whose shoes is those mine
how's it feel
hey call of duty it's gonna be inside
game pass and deuce is gonna be sick
today's stomach because they're gonna
see at the end of the show and then go
oh
no like you're home alone boy
oh no
[Laughter]
why they gotta have his face
oh no
listen y'all we got royalty in the
building we got a fellow
duke
my brother my co-host
the father dukes oh
the lord of the spoon
and oh predictor of all things but
that's the my brother
mr maddie plays how are we doing sir i'm
doing well thank you so much for having
me i apologize to everyone for being
late
i apologize i apologize not at all
brother we are so happy to have you we
missed we're gonna get right to the to
the nitty gritty i don't know if tom's
limited for everybody so you know we
talked about the state of xbox just real
quickly coming in you know where you're
at with that and then the prediction man
like so how we doing it man it's how we
do it
we need okay we need to know okay what
you need to start the show
what you need to end the show you need a
mic drop moment you know what i'm saying
yeah yeah i think i know a couple of
y'all
i wonder yes shout out to the following
example last day of video every year
right now but stay here right now
now
like just state of xbox coming to the
show and then let's get into these
predictions
yeah the state of xbox i don't think
it's as
dire as as some people make it out to be
but
i will say that they need to
hit the showcase out of the park i think
they need to restore the faith a little
bit for a lot of people who are lacking
in belief
um i don't know if they can fill in the
gap of starfield and redfall i have some
theories some ideas that maybe they
could but uh of course those are a
fool's hope uh but you know this is
uh yeah this is a a showcase that you
know we've said from the from the top of
the air cog on defining dukely we said
they need to nail this one this is one
that they can't afford to miss out on so
uh that message is even stronger now
with starfield and redfall missing
it's funny because you know when i i
talk about a show starter i remember
last year i'm bad with these because i
was like oh you you end the show with
starfield they begin the show at
starfield and i'm like where are they
going to end it with now
i don't know right so
uh you know for me like i think you
opened the show at starfield last year i
think you open with it again oh this
year would be my pick yeah yeah i think
you go back to back you kind of because
to me i view it like you're addressing
the elephant in the room quickly you let
everyone focus on what silence the
haters okay right right get it get it
out there
let people know what what they're gonna
be experiencing
um yeah exactly i could see some haters
yeah right like kind of remove the
distraction like it's very exciting but
i think because it's a ways out we're
not going to get anywhere close to the
half hour todd howard presentations we
typically get so you know i think like a
five-minute showing of some major
systems in the game we'll do plenty for
a lot of people i'm hungry for more
excited yeah so am i dude i'm i can't
believe it like next week we're
literally gonna finally see it and you
know after all these years like on my
channel i've been talking about this
game since like 2017 or 18 like it was
just this trademarking for a while we're
like oh yeah when will this happen and
it ends up being real and now we're
finally going to see gameplay so i'm
just stoked to to see it be actually to
materialize before our eyes but before
while you say that what the eeriest
timing just happened shout out to the
xbox game pass account who just tweeted
you us june 12th see you then starfield
star logos oh why are you talking i'm
like yo this is crazy man you doing it
making it happen continue your time will
you get into existence
see this is that insider that we need
it's not the insider we watched
oh my god
um
um
ending the show man
it's funny because this one kind of goes
hand in hand with the mic drop moment
but i'll give you an answer for each for
me
i feel like
you got to address a gap like something
that's been missing for a while i feel
like you got to go loud like something
that everyone's heard of and i've been
beating the star wars marvel dc drum for
a while
yeah get your get your pop culture game
in there i feel like you ended on an
exclusive
i would you know of course me being a
star wars fan boy like yeah give me an
exclusive star wars mandalorian yeah
something like that are we doing that
all right like that would be huge
specifically mandalorian like everyone
loves that was it wasn't that remember
that man delorean's supposed to be like
an mmo though i don't know
i think it's fake though something yeah
it was all those coalition was
supposedly involved with it though
coalition's making amanda lawrence
where's my money
it's just
it's just it's been in the nobody's
known anything but it's been around and
bounded about but that's about it
yeah yeah i've heard about whatever the
hell this thing is i always thought
coalition could make a punisher gang
yeah i said the same thing i agree
completely yeah i heard about it at the
beginning of this year but that source
was also the same one that was like
really telling me that starfield was
going to happen that year and we all
know how that went made a fool of myself
on that one
everyone
[Laughter]
yeah so to me like the show under is uh
you know red fall kinda did that where
it's like oh i didn't expect that it
just wasn't on the level of i think like
fanfare support where it's like whoa uh
so something that's like if you're gonna
do cg sting or something at the end make
sure it's a name that people know right
like red fall is this new thing arcane
struggle
i like arcane a lot valve could
definitely be that yeah about well
that's the thing i got two mic drop
moments
that's the spicier one yeah it's kind of
cool guys like you don't know
you know one of them you know one of
them i'm going hard for this one
you got you gotta yeah you can clip this
i think about it's coming out this year
i think that's gonna bite drop moment
yeah oh wow
yeah i think a vowed i think they they
push it out i i feel like
this delay
you ready for this
the fool in me is sitting here believing
so hard that this delay of starfill and
red fall was so catastrophic you had to
have a plan in place there had to be
something ready there had to be there's
too much money to be lost
so okay and you know maddie i agree with
you on in terms of
of
the fact they did it before the show
like you're supposed to be hyping the
show i felt like that kind of killed the
fight right
i just want to say one thing
all right for the footage just just i
very easy very simple very simple
it's something that uh potentially will
be yours just for that for that empty
space that was there for those two games
one game we don't know about another
game everybody seems to care so much
about but that that space that that that
november 11th whatever it was going to
be right
just put call of duty in there and game
pass listen
listen listen listen listen listen
for call of duty game pass you tell me
what the hell game pass numbers look
like right after that that same day
and i will show you a bunch of twitter
dudes with their playstations in the
store handing them in
the ride is over i gotta go over there
can i have a little man with this so i'm
just saying you know you don't really
have to join i don't want them to clip
your vows no no no we got that
we got to run that back
but i'm with you though if you out there
you out there we out there together go
get it
yeah break i i sorry i want you dropping
the megaton again because you're one of
the first right so again idol sloth get
it ready nothing but a bunch of people
make sure y'all clip this it's official
mr maddie plays the duke is saying it 20
22. so your thought process is from the
money loss from the two releases right
you're saying now they got to do
something so is it ready continue break
that break my phone yeah there's more to
it about's been in development longer
and i think a lot of people realize
it's been a good four plus almost five
years and yeah they had to build a lot
of assets from the ground up that takes
a while to do so it's it's very well
possible they make full use of all those
years that they were given um it's just
right now they're in such an interesting
spot coming to 2023 where i know some
people
will call me crazy for this i'm curious
what you guys think but i feel like
you're kind of gonna run into a
situation where the first half could be
contraband about star field red fall
other things we don't know about day one
game pass drops and i know xbox fans are
are hungry for content but i'm like now
you risk kind of blowing the whole build
up from 2018 in one two quarters okay
and to me that doesn't make sense either
you don't want them to stack on each
other the other alternative why i like
i'm not like all in on my own about
prediction if i'm quite honest
you look at it like well maybe you get
star feel out in the summer a vowed
which was going to come out in the
summer goes out to the fall now they can
add more they can polish it more they
have a lot of options but i just feel
like the the ability to accelerate it
like obsidian to me is like the could be
the insomniac for xbox with how how many
games they're releasing right like we've
heard about pentamete that's pretty much
a lot that's gonna be at the show
because josh sawyer is confirmed as much
if you read his twitter account
nail polish random 1.0
you know so they're i'm not going to act
like these games are as big as a ratchet
and clank in the spiderman i'm no fool
but
i'm talking about the quality and the
level of output for your console that
you're supporting yes and i mean just i
could see them doing that thing where we
were all sitting there wondering how did
you get miles morales and ratchet and
clank rift to part out in like a seven
month window and they just somehow did
it so we used assets
[Laughter]
and take away the jump button and just
pull it and act like this doing
something
you know
i'm messy leave me alone
i haven't played miles morales i can't
confirm or deny that
you know it's one of those situations
where i could see obsidian being that
team what's coming on pc just wait
yeah yeah just yeah just be patient
what i think is more more uh likely
as a as a fill-in and this will excite a
lot of people i don't i think it'll also
be used to like antagonize xbox fans a
ton which is is fair but i think it'll
come to playstation fans as i think this
is the year we get fallout remasters i
think
if you want to talk about something that
that fills in the gap realistically that
you could pull the trigger on in a
relatively quick manner
that could be developed alongside a big
aaa game probably at a support studio
and you look at the timing of the
fallout pipeline and you look how long
it'll be until we get anything else
whether it's pre-announced or not and i
just feel like
you know look broken clock is right
twice a day
you know this is the year that maddie
might finally get it right you know i'm
always i'm always like keeping an eye
out for it but this is the year i'm like
i'm gonna predict it i'm gonna put it
into the universe let's let's be great
let's make this happen let's wheel this
into existence
um i just feel like the timing makes a
lot of sense and again you know
a lot of people look at this as like an
xbox problem but bethesda while they are
owned by xbox i mean they do see the
revenue from their releases as well and
i i feel like they just lost their two
fall games yeah and you know
i feel like they almost had to have some
type of contingency plan in place it's
not the first time that they vacated the
fall
but even then there were there were
other things in place and right now the
only thing they got going on is a
fallout 76 expeditions thing that's
independent
well let me throw this
this alley to you
obviously
this isn't going to be anytime soon but
once that they come together right when
that starfish was like
we know something is probably in the
works microsoft looks like they approved
it
let's show them a logo for fallout new
vegas too
see yeah you perfect alley-oop beat me
to the punch here
uh that's where my head was at on you
know the other mic drop moment you were
asking me
like what do you do to drop the mic
and i feel like it would have hit a
little harder if you had starfield
coming out this year that was kind of my
plan is the the current the near future
and the far future that's what i was
saying like this year you're getting
start feeling red fall here's gameplay
for that then here's contraband here's
hellblade here's a valve like presumably
we're thinking like 2023 at the timing
of all that and then you show something
like new vegas and be like this is what
you're getting mad deep by the way
and that's what i thought was going to
be the game plan maybe that's still in
effect but
i could also see now them looking at
their layout and being like do we want
to announce something or show off a lot
of stuff that's coming out
and then announce stuff that's coming in
like 2027 like that right like i don't
know it would definitely create hype
but i don't know if it's the hype
they're looking for right it could be
bad hype like elder scrolls six style
hype oh yeah that's huge so maddie uh
i'm breaking program a little bit we
gotta find out some stuff from mr irish
this prediction show is wild if either
final fantasy 7 remake part two gets
announced or if a vow gets dated this
year you can have my knees and help
all right all right listen i'm telling
you all y'all dog believers in the chat
and i'm clipping it in 4k
right now i don't know probably for my
own safety i i didn't look while i was
we actually have a nice chat thank you
sometimes listen man look batty that
would be
massive you know especially
you know me and you've talked on
defining duke a lot about you know the
importance of fallout right the
importance of not having to wait to
almost a whole generation potentially
without getting because of star field
you know being in the mix now is this
new ip and you know elder scrolls so
that would be huge you're talking like a
rematch you're talking that
man that that would definitely get so
almost you're giving like the the the
past present
and then the future kind of of bethesda
and that wow yeah i i just you know
and again i gotta admit my bias looks
like you're you ain't gonna get me
excited for motorsport
it's not happening it's not like i bet
the need for horizon that's this open
world game where i could be a an idiot
you were not getting me excited for
motorsport that's just not happening
it's just one of those things and you
know we've heard a lot of rumors about
the gears collection mm-hmm our good
friend jess said he doesn't really know
about that he doesn't know if he's
buying into that so or maybe it was rand
i don't want to speak for jazz i think
you might have been rand
um you know i just feel like
this fall could kind of be disastrous in
the terms of familiarity we we laughed a
lot about the uh the the burger fries
it's like we might we might be looking
at a fall where they're like here's halo
infinite season three here's a gears
collection and here's motorsport eight
you not pumped for that
no
do not hype for that
give me a valid in 2022 all is forgiven
now it's like really hyped up about her
hellblade this
i just feel like that would be the oh oh
snap moment
to me just yeah if we're really looking
for a showcase that's going to surprise
i would i i mean
say in one of the games that people were
expecting deeper the first time you show
it and it's like it's actually coming
soon yeah um that could be impactful
especially because about from what we've
heard what we've read has the benefit of
looking a lot like skyrim so i don't
think it
it will struggle to sell people they'll
be like oh it's skyrim yeah yeah
it's more colorful so hey yeah maddie
isn't this fun
when they only have four studios and it
was like what do you think they're gonna
show i think they're gonna show halo i
think they're gonna show guests i think
they're gonna show forza
and now instead of it people is like i
don't know what they did
so the language that we're having now is
hyperbole and it's actually blowing
people's minds but the scary reality to
it is it could happen somebody here is
going to be right
[Laughter]
i can honestly say i want us to be boom
man i want to be born yeah boom
if that ever happened i'm going straight
to disney world
i can't get there you're going to play
my power forward
and i'm wearing the xbox shirt and i'm
like yo we paid for the play
at the end of the day
it's like you know what
when uh cognito asked wait hold on
slow mo said the dea has entered the
chat
i'm sorry
when you know when carl asks what the
state of xbox is right now it's like i
said state xbox right now i do feels a
little
a little shady
but it's right now like
there is so much down the line that we
don't even know about like i can
honestly say that
xbox is the only console holder right
now that they have so many shadow doors
that you don't even know is there
because they own so much stuff now
like you know playstation
unless they get some second party stuff
we kind of know what playstation gonna
do i would say nintendo's kind of like
i don't know what they're doing half the
time
they know what they're doing half the
time but yeah
they just have so many studios so many
opportunities they they
they have people like bethesda software
studios and up city under the same
company which if you had asked me five
years ago never would have happened ever
yeah they got so much potential it's
like what king said this is one of the
first times that we went to a prediction
show last year was a little bit the same
but it wasn't this bad work i absolutely
have no idea yeah yeah yeah it's really
rare right we i do know this i don't
know what to expect at all i do know
this um
last year they had 30 games that went to
straight to game pass
this year they're going to top that with
31. okay
right right
finish your thought maddie then i'll go
no i i was gonna just uh uh pass the
ball to the rest of the chat here and uh
just get the temperature on
persona on xbox do they oh
they put it out there it there's gonna
be the the the xbox japanese section of
the show they were talking about
there you go
that's fine that's mine
nobody said that yeah that was bad
that's why you're gonna get they're
gonna have the whole uh uh eastern uh
section that's gonna happen you know
you're gonna get final fantasy you're
gonna get death stranded because
kojima's gonna come out personally sign
the
contract
they're stranded right there
at the same time you're gonna get all
the personas and then sonic is gonna run
out and say not to die
[Laughter]
surrealism you got some hype i mean i
came in with zero realism as you can
tell
the biggest two avowed in 2022 and
persona on xbox man i might be batting
over three this show
let's see we're gonna see this is a big
one here's my who cares
sooner or later maddie you're going
backwards
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna hit a homer on
one of these years one of these days but
look like adding said i think the beauty
of this show is
that we know they're in a different
position because they have the studios
and we just don't know the the cadence
and what could happen but i'm gonna keep
it grounded
initially you know what i'm saying and
y'all know it's only released this year
is that what you're saying
i am not saying that y'all know i am
lord obsidian i think they are the
number one xbox game studio acquisition
right now until everybody else get their
stuff together but um yeah i think they
are going to absolutely dominate this
show i i think that you know we or
they're going to probably start it off
small we get the grounded 1.0 the
release just to say hey it's out
officially you got the stuff you know
just to kind of set the trend
i do think we get the project pentiment
with uh joshua sawyer's game you know
he's outside on twitter he's really
animate he seems pumped yeah it's
definitely going to be good he's been
very extra on twitter here whether it be
in the indie vein the double a vein but
anything else that's all it's been like
in general if you think about it yeah
yeah xbox has been outside that actually
everybody's been outside exile
entertainment oh nxt yeah they've been
outside popping off in exile man i love
them bill yeah great studio brian fargo
is not having it they letting people
know you know stop the cap we we out
here and we can do what we want to do
but um yeah i think obsidian is going to
dominate i really think so i just think
that like again that you start off small
you build the hype you get on what you
call the project pentagon out we get to
see if it's in the disco elysium kind of
vein or not whatever this scope is and
he he's just a plus with the stuff he
does and like everyone is saying
avowed a vowed i think is really going
to quell and shut a lot of people up i
think if it's anything like we've heard
shout out to jess corden any anything
that we've heard whether it be skyrim
with that color palette
and in the pillars of eternity universe
just shining i've heard rumors of other
elements i don't know you'll say but if
if if any of these things come together
with the narrative and the in the epic
nature now matty if it comes 2022 oh
yeah man
i get that i go down twitter
i know you're gonna pop off i will
record a video like while i'm live on
twitter just
really yelling at my camera letting
people know you doubted me you don't
have a quick question for you got for
everyone
how do you think people are going to
take the goldeneye 007
do you think that's going to hit like
people think it is or it's going to be
one of those things where it just didn't
didn't format
i think it will i think it will hit but
it's just i think it's what's the add-on
piece it's an add-on piece you know that
music
[Music]
how about
okay
let's keep hyperbolic here yeah let's go
let's keep the theme of the show
all right so this is a shadow drop i i
imagine like it's practically a lock
that they're gonna shadow drop this at
the the showcase
and
maybe io interactive pops up on stage
it's like that double o seven game we're
working on we're now the double 07 box
oh wait wait wait wait wait wait are we
we talking lord acquisition talk oh no
no no no no no no no no no
they don't have a green jacket maybe
maybe like this is either it could be
one of two things right xbox as king
said like they've had a ton of games in
game pass announced last year i think it
was like 28 out of 30 or something like
that
so either they're like we're going day
one game pass for 007 or
maybe this is one of those rare
exceptions where they're just like
here's double o seven
okay a little double of seven action
okay okay that's gonna be a show with
double o seven
indiana jones
bigger ip big ip oh no for sure it'll be
crazy if they showed that that
double-oh-seven remake and then they
showed you a trailer for the new
double-oh-seven game
okay i see where you're going look man
continue calling yeah yeah that's cool
um
yeah like a vow like i said i think they
really did i don't know about the i
think it was forgot who said out of
worlds
too i forgot it was king kids right i
don't know because they just announced
the trailer you know what i'm saying and
it to be so early and just for them to
even do that i thought that was just big
that was a flex they began working on
that in 2019 king might be honest oh man
listen if they do that
and i get like
bruh
like i already know how i feel about it
what happens if they do that we that we
don't even know and out of worlds comes
out in 2020
yeah y'all going too far
but look hey they got more assets for
that
tim will appreciate that still here like
tim
the reason why i go so hard for them is
because we hear all this
mismanagement talk
you hear all this we don't know what's
going on but there's one signee that
since they've been with xbox they have
not made a whack game yet they have hit
the ground running they've never made a
way multiple projects going on and i
don't
know
what the black rock obsidian
don't put respect on the black rocker
that's what obsidian is so look
obsidian's made of water and lava
[Laughter]
listen they forged from fire
background studios
shout out to playgrounds don't play
around with the duels respect the
coalition talking about your team but
i'm talking but it's my team
it's my team you know what i'm saying
you know i love my quarterback and the
thing is
i think they're gonna dominate so we got
that now we go into what i think it's
kind of also the rubber possibility
manny if we gonna fight here but i do
think ubisoft plus is a lock at this
point i think ubisoft plus comes in
there and they say that's nice that we
did classics over there that's the
classic
curator yeah that's the reebok classic
here is
but we've been hearing like three years
that this service is coming together
they're on twitter
[Music]
i don't think it'll be in baked in
no you just gotta buy it yeah it's like
we have it it's already confirmed it's
all it's coming it's all no it's common
the question is is it baked into
ultimate or is it it's separate thing so
i'm gonna amazon prime and you go get
showtimes
i'm thinking it's going to be what they
did with playstation they're going to
take a certain amount of games and
they're going to dub the service or make
this tier
whatever you want to call it don't bring
that over here we don't want that you
know something like that i i don't think
it's going to be the wheel we over here
we are used to full boat sir no no no we
don't we do day and date over here don't
don't be coming over here with your half
baked little uh
rated stuff that's that's for them dudes
over there that don't do damn date over
here we are used to the premium sir so
if you're going to do the hyperbole
let's take it to the top
just for a quick we got
hundreds hit the like
hit that like button you guys let's get
that above like seven hundred please
please so yeah look i i'm going with the
ubisoft joint i'm going with separate i
think it'll be there i think they'll
have a lot to show there um the indie
scene i think is gonna dominate a little
bit more than some people may like i
think they're gonna have a lot of cool
stuff i think as dust falls is gonna be
something that they really get behind a
lot of stuff that is in the cut but to
everyone's point i do think we will see
it kids said it we're gonna get a lot of
gameplay from a lot of stuff i think
gameplay is going to be very power mount
for them they know they got to get the
energy up they got to get people to
believe especially red fall especially
star field and now i actually feel like
they're going to show so much gameplay
call that they're not going to have as
many games as they generally always have
at these events it's possible it's
possible
it's a good it's a good thing so my
thing now is so with the start
i'm with maddie man i think
you got to let people know because the
delay was the blow
you gotta let people know todd here we
go
talk to him show him so this way you
quell the haters you shut people up this
is it it's moving it's shaking we're
flying it don't look right and what if
you get a craig face
what is your
last time we did something in this
magnum
craig face showed up but that is not the
same sir three foot three came outside
and they still was locked into their
date with craig faith but i don't know i
think they dancing in the mirror too and
phil said not again buddy
i'm with you
where i'm with you is i don't think i'm
sorry kid i don't think there's no no
date when that game play comes out
at the end it'll be like summer
or you know it'll be like they put a
window they might not they yeah they
might just shut up and say you see you
when we see you but now
oh you don't
i do personally feel like if they don't
put any form of window or anything we
might not see that to holiday next year
what not but to to maddie's point i
don't care what's your date kid what was
your day for stuff you said three three
three three three three three twenty
three oh okay okay so yeah
all right so look
i do think like i said they will show it
it it behooves them not to put a date
after 11 11. that's just my opinion but
we will see i just don't know how if
they delayed it how they could just
gauge like yeah we'll actually only need
a couple more months right like that
quickly just yeah i agree and they'll
get crucified yeah i i i'm out of here i
think that they're gonna
leave themselves room for
if they're gonna schedule something i
could see red fall being getting the
concrete date because that was supposed
to be summer and i think that that could
be the first one to go
with
with starfield it makes sense for them
to give themselves they shouldn't block
themselves in any amount of time they
should give them okay they're going to
give a date you know i don't think
they're gonna and i think that it's a
smart way to do because
the game's there
it's the logo like and here's my thing
like
the way they the way they even said it
was a small delay they even said it in
the wording of that like to me you don't
come out first in june and don't give a
date because then you're gonna make me
think that it's not a small delay so
like you're not
[Music]
yeah they got they other deals popped up
they looked over the game was like oh my
god here we go here we go we ain't doing
that on my segment no we're not doing
really think it's like some conspiracy
theory they gotta they gotta fit it in
there they don't want to step on their
toes with this game and it's highly
anticipated they want maddie to enjoy
himself with this game man maddie has
been anticipating it and he can bear
with a little weight as long as it's
polished nice
which is why they delayed it
call of duty's coming in game passes
we're gonna see where this shot is
she'll go down but look i say that and i
think as far as ending the show
you definitely you gotta have
i'm not gonna commit to exactly which i
got some candidates
but whatever it is that you end has to
be new ip this this is too big i'm going
to give it to you i'm going to give you
thank you new ip
and it got to be graphically
political outstanding i'm about to give
it
this guy over here talking about
breaking ftc and federal laws with his
prediction but i'm political okay fine
listen anyway
graphical fidelity new ip
i think it you got to give compulsion
that one
what game is it project midnight i think
okay midnight you end with project
midnight you sho this is the future this
is this this is studio no one's talking
about we've battled record
phil saying
that the sleep people are sleeping on
compulsion
we've had compulsion on
we know it's hashtag just one on some
level yeah with third person over the
shoulder
i don't know if they're going to be the
graphical uh
uh
you know where they wow you i think when
you talk about that
compulsion uh
the the gear studio i guess yeah like
coalition yeah i think they're more up
your alley but with
what i've heard with that you heard what
you heard was that when they started out
um with xbox they were pretty much were
like
hey
we're a small studio but we don't want
to be treated like a special example
that's what i'm thank you you know and
they made their case
and you know i think that uh you might
have been like
they got a new studio right
and um i think that what they showed
phil impressed them all right
that's what i heard that's what i heard
so by again my thing is i know
the past work and i understand people's
been telling like yo it's not gonna be
triple a look at the pair i get them
entirely based on past work i'm saying
they've been working on this and now
with this budget and now the ramp up i
think it may surprise more than people
think so that that's what i'm rolling
with yeah with the with them too um i
know that you've had him uh we also had
him on
uh the xbox round table the the editions
that got cancelled somehow but um
that guy let me tell you something
he might be the guy that pushes
xbox or just microsoft really
he might come up with the type of uh uh
like really
risky
but for fun type game idea like he he's
willing to put it this way he's willing
to
take risks if you remember we happy few
years yes risks
think about like what the game play yes
you get happy bro
it was the concept was fire it was just
the funny i'm with you so to me it's
like now you have that they have these
great ideas now you got the budget
here's the thing let me ask maddie this
quick question hellblade won
right how many people were that studio
if we have to say how anybody know like
well size of 12. size of hellblade one
if you had to guess what if we were
guesstimating it it was 12 people you
don't know that for sure
oh it was my bad kick i'm sorry it was
small right so
wearing different hats so this is the
way i say that to say this because i see
people yo then double it listen if they
had 12 and they made a hellblade
right you mean to tell me that
compulsion with 150 to 200 can't make
something graphically nice that's all
i'm saying i'm just saying i don't want
people hold on let me finish
i don't want people to say
that it's out of the realm of
possibility that's why people act like
there's no way i'm that's all i'm saying
i'm saying there's a possibility that
people people are just looking at the
past work you have to in order to get to
where you got to go naughty naughty dog
wait a warrior
people sleeping like i know
you know where these game companies
start that's what i said they're still
progressing so let's not lock them
automatically in this small little
cutesy indie artsy box you know what i
said
that's all i'm saying i don't think that
has anything to do with i think that's
the type of games they like to make they
like that artwork they like that i get
that all i'm saying again people got the
difference there's a difference between
scope
and graphical i'm saying the graphical
fidelity could improve that's all i'm
not saying
100 hour
you know
i'm not saying that
all all the technology that they have
available from all the studios that they
have acquired over the years uh and they
shared they already they came on the
show and they told us they share tech
with yes
shout out to one bad mother compulsion
is using ue
unreal engine five tech see that's what
i'm saying like
people want to keep them in this box and
no one knows i don't know but they can't
say
definitely they know
i think the game's going to look nice
but i just don't think it's going to
push the needle
well like like
in the case it's like
talking about
hellblade i wildly disagree one of the
things i heard about hellblade 2 was um
or just the developer um
the reason why they liked going on with
uh x
xbox was obviously
um you know they would get support but
one of the things that they like to
dabble with their tech that they use
and the like the the to to use it the
equipment
it's like really expensive yeah now you
look at what they're doing they're like
that whole game is like motion
cap like it's cap like that big monster
i don't know if you saw the uh yeah
they showed like the inside of it where
the guy's crawling around
um but they but they the technology that
they use that studio alone um
is like top of the line like they one of
the reasons that like i said i heard is
because they had an open-ended budget
for
tech you know what i mean they could
spend a ton of money so yeah i agree
with you i don't think we should sell
them short that's all right
my opinion though like i really feel
like the the big graphical cogs oh yeah
the coalition's the playground i know
where you are exactly
i'm not saying that when they come out
it's gonna be the best they're gonna
blow away all the studio i'm not saying
what i'm saying it's gonna look nice
just talking about like pushing the
needle all i'm saying is unreal engine
five i think it's going it's a strong
possibility by default that should look
good yeah that's what i'm saying so
let's just let's keep them out of the rc
box please that's all it does so anyway
i'm done with that and then my
ridiculous okay let's get it you know
all right let's get it
lights come out you know what i'm saying
phil comes on
you know
one last thing thank y'all for coming
out russell simmons voice but we got one
more thing oh god
we got one more thing y'all the light
still you know what i'm saying you've
known this man to give you
the most epic
franchises
in gaming you've known this man
also some of the most boring
fix
we've known this man to be one of the
most eccentric but one of the great
developers in our time you know what i'm
saying
and the lights turn back on he made a
ups and and to double down on my theory
while i give you even more confidence
did you see the xbox tweet just recently
yes
it said xbox xbox xbox and it had
flashes of all the people at xbox shows
over the years
xbox xbox xbox and there was one face
that you had to catch
one face that you don't normally see
from back in the day one face that rules
you had to freeze
and that
and now we talk in letters of intended i
they got to translate at the bottom have
the letter intent to make a game with
xbox it'll be using the azure server
technology
we will it will be there
[Music]
[Laughter]
two boxes
grub comes out
they had like a thing where they signed
the contract i think it was uh yeah
they go
move the couches
yeah
the playstation couch just come back out
sit down bro
it would be epic zeitgeist the symbol is
king fix your face
phil turns to the screen and says this
is how we deliver our game
[Music]
looks at the screen and says this is in
your head this isn't what happened
jeff gruff comes out with the catcher
this is his big scoop he calls it before
everybody and they do the signing live
i'm very ridiculous but let me have this
because
a broken clock is right twice a day
crazy that's not so crazy because yes
jeff jeff had that that report so and
jeff's pretty good at what he does
listen man so we got that and like i
said that that would be my i want to do
the last trade because i know when we go
along and we gotta finish yeah okay so
look last joint this is the fun the one
that i love we do
gotta have some fun with it
okay
the longest running segment on the
prediction series the xbox bethesda
showcase
is an l
if
so what would absolutely
disgust you
if they came out i want to start with
tim dawk first i want to know what tim
dog first you know say god damn right no
man
and then we only go tim dawg kid maddie
than the lord so tim
you are the og you've been there from
the beginning project natal you've been
there through the dark times decided
what would disgust him dog
i got the answer
they're hyping up or we're hyping up
game play
like they show like [ __ ]
like you know
i when i listen my idea of e3 gameplay
[Laughter]
no i act like they're communicating with
each other on your left oh you're sick
right if they didn't show the game play
god i think that that part of the show
is is to answer
a lot of um
the uh the the
the problems that they had with last
show a lot of complaints so if they if
they just showed get i want to see i
want to see game play i want to see it
now i want to see it like though six
minutes right five minutes i don't want
to see three three second clip you know
what i mean you don't want to see
influencers in social media you don't
want to see the streaming personalities
come out and say hey we're having so
much fun in this battle royale oh you're
six
i like when they take it from the
beginning or they take a level and they
just play it that's my favorite is when
they play and they don't have any kind
of uh doctoring they just play the game
so um but if they hear if they really
play around with the gameplay but yeah
listen like i said
[Music]
phone yeah i got you you made campos
just look like a child out there
it was out of here listen campos is a
great fighter too but yeah he just got
schooled badly it was kind of just
nothing ah yeah i know attica you guys
are awesome love you bro just keep keep
keep up with the good work man next year
you guys are gonna be even bigger so
like i said it's
it's it's
a long game you already know next year
we hope to see you again in person
or the short notice [ __ ] exactly
set it up right and do it right no doubt
brother have a good one
and i know a lot of y'all are saying hey
uh why ain't y'all telling tim you to
watch his legs i told you
he's the godfather
salute man
xbox mafia you'll remember that episode
was classic thank you yeah
salute brother kid smoke
the best spot
your twitter account i know how you get
[Laughter]
sometimes it's loose i love you mr that
but i will say
you do have some of the most hilarious
tweets that i do want to click like and
i can't but i won't be wanting to but i
can't so what
i do i know it's just so messy i'm like
damn i can't i totally like it too i
want to but anyway keep doing it
the xbox bethesda showcase would be an
absolute hell would absolutely disgust
kids move if
salutations
good job everybody have you wanted to
say that
greetings society
[Laughter]
i
[Music]
regardless of what they show right
the show ends
and there's still nothing coming out
this year
there's no 2022.
kid that's lit i like that
that would drive like that would
literally morally destroy me
because if they just fraud they show
this stuff but there's no release
yeah that's me
i like them i like that it wouldn't be
worse if there's nothing coming out this
year and then don't she release dates
for a vow for anything like at all
listen i like that so let's go
mr maddie place hmm
he's gonna take my xbox but does this
showcase
don't take it be an l with disgust
maddie if
starfield sucks oh
i see
yeah sorry sorry i just
that's kate that goes right into kig's
leg smoove got the best answer but like
i just think for me
what would eat away at my soul for
months at on end
above even no games because i'm used to
that with x-rays
just
it's just if i saw a star feel i'm like
this looks so mid-dude
we go oh no
keep it in the cooker like because i
yeah it's one of those things where
an average showing is worse than a bad
showing to me that's what i was saying
yeah like if i just see like exactly the
halo infinite debacle i'm just like man
like even they couldn't avoid it reddit
postcode they got to be they got to be
ready because like
people are coming hot off 76.
you got the power of microsoft behind
you people are going to be breaking this
thing down power up because it compels
yeah they need to show out really strong
with this one and i just worry sometimes
that like
you know if it doesn't what is it what
happens right this was supposed to be
kind of what defines the fall originally
for this year so to me like as a huge
bgs fan that would sting like if i saw
it i went
now like this isn't it kind of reminds
me of how i felt with 76 like it was
exciting to get a new bgs game but i
remember they showed like this small
10 second gameplay clip of pvp and i
went oh gosh
why
because the other thing we gotta
remember is starfield's on a new engine
it's on creation engine two yes
big deal right so to me it's like if i
saw that went wow the new engine new ip
the microsoft money oh
it looks bad it's hard to imagine but
like that's what would make it
devastating right is this
near impossible feat it feels like to be
accomplished so yes i'm just hoping that
they let the gameplay do the talking i
think half of bethesda's problems
someone wrote in chat so it reminded me
lord metroid did is but that's the kind
of talks themselves into a corner
sometimes right like 16 times the detail
you see 76 versus font four and you're
like
what were you smoking for you stage man
like what happened so like you know that
that's the other thing is i hope todd
just says here's our new ip we're sorry
for the delay
please enjoy a glimpse of the future and
just let the game speak
um and then from there hopefully it
looks good but to me outside of of
course 2022 being vacant that would be
the most
next devastating thing to me it's just
starfield the game i'm most excited for
doesn't look great because i have other
hopes and ambitions but of course
they're like stupid ones right
not coming out this year i'm gonna be
like okay
that's an l i can take i love it
darfield looking bad that's the future
man no you're right you're right that
would have cataclysmic impact and did it
you start to halt the talks will start
what's going on oh yeah that'll be all
twitter will be lit for another month
that's such a good point because you
look at all the what's happened with the
initiative and all these studios working
with xbox um undead labs got scooped up
in the rumor mill and it's just like you
know you don't want to create this
perspective of you're making things
worse even though we've had examples of
like psychonauts 2 wasteland 3 i know
they're
they were multi-platform but those are
examples of games that got better
through xbox right um
you know forza horizon of course yes i
think halo infinite if they didn't give
it the year delay week and they actually
pushed down in 2020 that would have been
catastrophic so
you know there is an impact that's
positive but that doesn't matter in the
now right we live in an industry of like
what have you done for me
today yes
that only applies to microsoft yeah
no well well said rather well said lord
addict this is this topic was created
for you
it's all literally you're the origin of
this
the xbox podesta showcase
is an l
it would disgust lord adam
if
i feel like
this would be just as bad if not i would
be probably just as bad as maddie's as
if they've okay this is like microsoft's
way thinking okay we delayed star field
now we can like lessen starfield's
presence at this and we'd have seen like
a story trailer almost no
of the gameplay in the ship
if i go let me just get lower you get
another you get more
when they come out with the round table
again they start talking
let me point out
yeah everyone at microsoft that might
watch this let's go if i leave the show
and don't see a good amount of gameplay
i'ma be pissed
more pissed at no favor though cause you
know how you get with fable i already
see but i i don't know next year's
different i don't expect fable this year
what but next year i don't see fable
next year microsoft
oh yeah so i just don't yeah i just
don't want them feeling like they can
well we could just show
that what we were gonna show
at this event at like the video game
awards
because it's closer to the launch date
that's what i'm scared of i don't think
that's going to happen i think you're
probably going to see what they were
going to show you regardless but i do
think that little the little evil demon
on my shoulder that's like sitting there
whispering in my ear addict there you go
so you [ __ ]
oh my god jesus
look yeah we lose we lose
plus i don't want to see minecraft i
know we're going to oh there no yo
you don't want to see minecraft on the
stage they show you minecraft and it
ain't no ray tracing or that
double thing oh my god
she does say that they're working on
like two games
for the
for minecraft like
working on two minecraft style games or
something like that what is world edge
doing
yeah world's edge oh man yeah i don't
know but oh look let's get the keg i
need this one i need this for my soul
the xbox but that's the showcase
it's watching
but his face is twisted
no is it let's discuss him what would it
be an l for you
no no okay so um if if
i have to piggyback off a kid because
kid actually took my thing if they had
no games to to fill
said uh
gaps from these two highly anticipated
earth-shattering the world microsoft
life depends on it games
god forbid games thank god
oh no
[Laughter]
they got craig face
okay that sounds like whatever um
[Music]
if they don't fill a void with actual
stuff that we are anticipating anyway
you know uh
i expect game pass to have a very
healthy
end of the year i mean it's been very
healthy actually right now to be honest
with you from the beginning of the year
all the way up to now and if somebody's
going to tell you that that it's not
healthy then you know i point to sniper
elite um i point to
uh
my trek to yomi i point to
um
you know
mlb the show for all you met fans and
yankee fans and all you guys out there
that can't get to the ballparks because
financially it's crazy but you got the
two slices of pizza that you guys we
call game pass you know cause you know
pizza in new york yeah two slices
fifteen dollars we outside over here
that's game pass right so two slices get
you in to play mob the show right you
sit down on your couch and you have a
good time with your friends can't do
that on the other side of the street why
because you got to buy it for 70. that's
a lot of slices
we don't want you to buy a pie we just
want you to buy two slices and keep it
moving yes but
that that would be the l for me
if um if the game pass uh the the the
platform that tim eloquently pointed out
this this is the platform
this is this is exactly what it is
don't be bamboozled and fools uh because
i don't know how many people out there
running around finding series x's and
playstation 5's silicon ain't doing it
right you can get a bunch of little mans
i can attest to it i got the whole house
full of them you know what's funny king
and i know i might get a lot of slack
for this but i would sacrifice games
this year for a valve star field and red
fall to look good
i i i want i i don't have any fear since
last year they were uh um a producer of
the year
right
um my my my feelings of fear is is
alleviated because of that whole thought
process with that they did something in
metacritics history 12-year history that
has only been done by that company and
it took that company to build their self
up from the doldrums from there
everybody says that 70 metacritic that's
not true and it wasn't true last year so
we're not going to overlook it and act
like well they're going to go revert
back to norm they didn't revert back to
norm all last year from the second half
their second half team now this is the
second half jordan is coming out with
pimping in the bulls and they're going
to spawn and it's about to be a rat so
you y'all think y'all won but you know
it's just like reggie miller running
down the court squeezing his neck it's
over
and you really think june 12th is going
to be nice for you it's not going to be
nice
only thing that can happen yes
yes
the l could be where is that if the
platform doesn't sustain the excellence
it has been sustained since the
beginning of the year and i doubt any
playstation fans gonna tell me it hasn't
been excellent because we have you your
first party game inside game pass so
hopefully throughout the rest of the
year we're going to get the final
fantasy that will fill that gap whoa you
know we will get other games day and
date that we do know about that's coming
out def loop y'all was raging about that
remember it was a nine it was a nine so
it's going to be inside game pass it's
going to be games there
so if they don't fill those gaps that's
an l okay no if you take an l for me i
don't want to see death loop oh
i didn't play it you played it right you
beat it on playstation right five i
don't wanna see i seen that at eight
state of plays i don't want to see it
anymore i want to see it on my platform
i want to partake in a new dlc yeah okay
maybe that's why
i don't want it like loki
[Laughter]
shows up and unlike maddie i think that
game was a great game but i don't want
to see it here because it's like i seen
it at state of play not one thought
twice
think about it we saw um elder scrolls
online at fallout 26 last year we will
see def loop like we have oh my god
but it's just it's launching in game
pass like why wouldn't you be happy for
your first party title a kid what's
crazy is i want to see
star field game play last year
that was unhearable but king doesn't
feels like me not wanting to see a game
that came out last year that we saw
eight times before it's on price it's
unimaginable this is the problem maddie
and you has partaking in this fruit and
you told me it was delicious
disrespectful it's not fruit
you played like prey before yes okay
you've already played death soup okay
moon crash the expansion for prey yes
okay you've absolutely played death okay
so i like okay
you're giving me more of the stuff i
like
first off first off all right hey don't
don't listen to nothing that man said
they gave us nothing like friends
it's actually
charisma and personality unlike
pregnancy
hey
hey
give me more stuff that i like for free
anyway look like so that's so that that
was your joint that was just if they
don't fill a gap for the rest of the
year for game pass game pass is the
platform don't be don't be funny might
as well be quick or attic still flying
it would be cataclysmic if there's no
starfield
with maddie i gameplay that might
actually be worse than seeing other than
not seeing it like yeah cause yeah you
you delay this joint
hey you still don't show are you are you
dancing around it
and you still we
you ain't let that's my heart like that
yeah yeah okay buddy i just got to add
up all right don't go but i think the
bigger thing that would piss me off
because you know how i feel about this i
know attic feels the same is if they put
starfield in jeff keeley's show i'd be
like
they got the logo on they brandon to
promote for the next day
i'll catch the cliff notes in the xbox
show if they give star feel to him all
right guys make sure you go down to
building 12 and that's where it's going
to be
but maddie why did they show you a story
trailer and say stay tuned for the 12
for the gameplay
[Music]
now what if it's episode four of the
yo if they come out with that round
table and i see them around and there's
the all met kids right now i don't know
i don't think it's realistic if they if
they announce on that stage that the
activation deal was done and all their
games go in the game fast oh that would
be correct that day right there that day
right there that day
right yeah it's the day that i have a
podcast every day dedicated just to xbox
if you come on that stage and phil throw
the mic on the floor he don't just drop
it
right
the deal's done
and they bleed
rips off no no no this is how it goes
king he comes on there for the xbox show
he says the activision deal's done he
throws the mic on the floor rips his
shirt off and there's an overwatch shirt
under double child
no no no no the lights go dark and sam
fisher come out he said we got that too
[Music]
so all of that was an act that they
gonna play nice and they gonna rip the
contracts upside down
since we're talking reaching such a
scenario then you hear the playstation
he's like yeah we bought that too yo you
messing y'all messy moving on from y'all
messiness yeah
[Laughter]
everything
that's like get married and you find out
your spouse or someone else after that
what's that organization called that's
going after them right now fdc
phil just looked at the screen take that
after yeah
no no the crazy thing is they they find
out that the deal went through with no
consent degree they was like so all that
stuff we said
[Laughter]
yeah if they come back with that where
game pass exists talk you know that's
where they religious on the deal but
look i'll finish off the last dig i
think for me um maddie knows how i feel
and the floor is a segment and i know
i'm getting killed by the motorsport
community i i know y'all love your game
yeah what's your simulation i get it oh
here you go bacagh
does not want to see two forces back to
back
back-to-back
20-minute segment
before that's the piss break of the
showcase for sure yeah
you better minimize
show it
people want their game we don't call it
doesn't like it i understand
people want their game let them have it
but please
i want them on and off there i can't
hear the burger shaking for that long
i just can't have and then the last
thing
i heard rumors of some
jazz puck device and
if
commercial and people around it and
spend time talking about services and
family plans and look jimmy i could take
the puck device over to my friends
there's a place
for no games being shown because we got
a long segment about this value of
departments
yeah you know they don't show that then
they do not come out there with little
jimmy in the family
and the part of the device
like what
is there's places to show hardware it's
not here do i not come out there with
the hardware
and the services and the puck i don't
want to say you don't want the family
planning hey hey hey hey you know what
thank you
they can give that to jeff
yeah give that to jeff give him let him
sit around and can't fire with you
well send that to digital foundry like
you did before yeah let them let them
test the the speed it don't matter who
gets it just don't just keep the puck at
minimum
away from
but that's
[Laughter]
show y'all no polls no extra fluff we
had some fun with it everybody around
salute mr boomstick excel salute tim
dawg salute kids move and of course by
defining duke brother mr maddie plays
let's do some outros let's start with
the best buy first can't smoove the
legend we had to make it right for kid
we had to make it right it was a trans
it was a flag on the field by isla
podcast i'm calling myself out kid was
supposed to be in there it was just too
late and i forgot so kiss move you're
back where you rightly belong where can
i find people find you what you got
going on sir
you guys can find me on uh twitter
kidsmove
youtube kidsmove um just put out
a video or so a couple days ago but
thanks for having me i i like um yeah i
caught uh addict on a flag on the play
when i saw the promotion i was like i
was like nobody called so
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
what's funny is i was talking to him and
he's like yeah if you could hear a kid
like carl try to like come up with
something to say and he's like whoa you
know you know he was on last year it's
like but so was boom yeah i was like
how did we oh damn he was like yeah we
got nothing to say we got that we got we
caught it we busted we made we really
right we made it it's all good it's all
good still love it stay here watching it
um but um happy to be here uh also to
share the uh the um
the screen with mr matt he plays you
know one of my favorite youtubers for
the year so uh
no doubt so that's where what else i can
find you kid
information out there where do people
know oh yeah at kidsmove twitter
kidsmove on youtube and um
always in the ironworks chat on uh
sundays
you already know and of course
defining duke the man
called me to the big leagues
i was so happy when i got that call i
was just like yo i wonder who they gonna
pick
let me see where it's gonna go
i got the call
i went from triple a you know what i'm
saying they're kind of called the best
one
and now we do this amazing show together
i'm so proud of what we're building and
the camaraderie the way people
understand the way you run that show
behind the scene it's our show but it's
like i love the the the the cadence and
the fun and how you mix it up and what
we're doing and having so much fun and
of course the lsm fam so where can you
find people find you we got retro what
we got we got cooking yeah we got we got
a lot to plug here give me a moment
let's go get the bars off uh yeah so my
main channel mr maddie plays uh you'll
find me there talking a lot about xbox
uh which we did a lot today so if you're
into that type of stuff you can find me
there um of course more on xbox as cog
has said defining duke it's our show we
run together yeah best xbox pot
uh really proud of what we're building
there we're growing fast and um it's
just something that we just want as many
people listening to as we possibly can
so please do give that a listen massive
episode with xbox two up now yeah i was
gonna say our episode just went live
with xbox two it was randolph thor and
uh jess cornyn joining us for a a mega
prediction show
uh where you might hear some of the same
predictions here
uh there are many more to go through so
check that out yes studio by studio
breakdown and then retro rebound is my
nostalgia channel over there it's grown
fast we just dropped a review for sonic
unleashed because everyone's loving on
sonic frontier so i was like
it's all about that nice modern sonic uh
so yeah they just went live it's been
doing really well so if you're into that
type of stuff i'm over there and then my
twitter account at g27 status
no no brand synergy
i always would ask you that like where
did that come from
yeah uh it's an old youtube channel oh
okay and i went to go
it's something that i would love to
change but someone
took that yes
somebody got you a joint and i was like
what the wow
[Music]
you know what
you know what maddie for for
feesley price of fifteen dollars i'll
give you your stuff back
ten dollars a month you can have it back
i might have to take you up on that yeah
because uh
that was in 2015 and i asked them to
delete the account so i could take it
they said okay i will and then they
literally wrote in the display name
deleting account not the real mr maddie
plays and i'm like
you're going to delete it it's still
there so they want to check it out yeah
that's crazy uh but yeah my twitter is
at g27 status uh if anyone wants to
follow me for
incredible takes that are fully educated
then you know i think that's the place
to go for some of the best reviews of
the game oh thank you you already yeah
we just dropped our diablo immortal
review too that was fun
that was that was a hell of a time so
yeah just thank you for having me and i
apologize again to people watching into
of course the lords i apologize for
being late oh you're good brother
working on my game and uh did
working on some i'll explain to you
behind the scenes
but uh yeah we were working on some
assets that took way longer
brother you're doing i'm doing the
lord's work real game development
one day maybe we'll be talking about it
here
all right
launching gamepad right here
you get a chain first then you know
welcome to death
little click button that you get
summoned by by the force you got to
go done
anyway lord addict and salute by bro
you don't realize how much he puts
behind the scene to get this to happen
like so many people he reached out to to
get one of the most amazing community
intro starts that we've never done so
many people contributed and responded to
him so many people gave us stupid
footage there was people we couldn't
even add you know he puts his heart and
soul behind the scenes attic show is
moving out here you know what i'm saying
he doesn't get his flowers people think
oh it's cog and king and and that no
attic needs his flowers put respect on
his name and i'm tired of y'all so i'm
not gonna say names acting like he is
not an integral and major part and the
co-host of this show so let's put
respect on lord attic thank you brother
you worked hard we stayed up late last
night i'm proud of you i don't give you
your flowers enough sometimes and i want
to give you your flowers i would
disagree if i could just interrupt by
the way not not about lord i being the
king but i'm saying about it
about you giving flowers you you're very
complimentary of him and um
do it more of course but i'm just like
you know what
every time we're on the show
i just want him to cry yeah we gotta get
him cry one day one day
but um
[Laughter]
he's not dead i just don't have that
emotion but i'll salute you brother this
was tremendous last night yeah people
think i'm uh the w
well jeffy said you was the tokyo
yeah i'm the token white guy in the
podcast i'm only here for a white crowd
ridiculous
unheard of
no doubt brother where can the five
people find you what you gotta go though
you can follow me on twitter at lord
addict iop uh you can find me on
now on youtube at gaming addict uh i did
i am gonna be releasing a lot of like my
in-depth stuff on what i wanna see from
star field
uh avowed also what i want to see like
at the overall show in general like just
more in-depth thing than what i did on
here uh so definitely go and look at
gaming addict on youtube what's funny is
uh the for people that was at the
beginning definitely go back and watch
the
starting screen we put a lot of
community people in there just saying
what they wanted from the show
kid smooth actually had one in there but
when we put him in at the last minute
because saul obviously couldn't do it i
yanked his out of the rest
i was like it's kind of like regarding
him to tell us there that him to tell us
here
uh you know we do got a couple more that
i'll probably stitch together for next
week right before the actual show uh so
definitely look into that uh this show
actually has changed three times we had
different panels three different times
one of them i'll have to say because
they said because uh you know defining
duke worked uh jazz and
and ran to the core so we had to give a
day off maddy
we had we have originally james and rand
was supposed to be on this show
but we had to apologize
we had to push them out because we i try
to have uh like jazz have a heart attack
because he'd be in this cause he was
still gonna come and we was like brother
we got another show lined up for you
yeah y'all break yeah yeah so i mean do
you want me to stay with next weekend i
mean we could do it i mean we might
people gonna
we're gonna have kids move jazz and ran
on next week we used to call it the
aftermath of the xbox show uh so
definitely look into that uh you know
i'm sure it's either gonna be a very
very lit podcast or very very poor
podcast depending on how the show goes
you know what's crazy
all the stuff we said we don't want to
see if that's the paw if that's the show
that'll be funny yeah
i appreciate it for coming out we had
almost 1200 people in here you know we
almost have a 800 likes before the end
of the podcast you know you guys show up
here uh left and right now keep in mind
we are going to read your super chats
we're going to get the intros let people
out then we'll start reading them
correct there's like a billion of them
so just can't leave people hostage while
we read them yeah just just just bear
with me guys yes and of course
the legendary prophet
of xbox the one who gets everybody's
perspective check he check me they
tired of these dudes talking y'all
forgot how the top of this year where i
was like yeah he kind of right no it was
guys it's a difference a week what a
week
and two game delays can make exactly all
i hear when i hear microsoft bells
because i have bells even microsoft
i'm walking on sunshine
like
and don't feel good
that's what i'm saying all right now
look at that y'all talk about delays and
stuff i feel real good so shout out to
everybody that showed up um shout out
first of all
okay so y'all think addicts just do that
right
i told attic yo every every every week
i'm like you're at it here's a picture
please put up a thumbnail
and he'll go put up a thumbnail uh
program the show get the show ready for
chaos i i have i mean um combat talk
with the king if i have a problem
actually like yo let me help you out
over here okay so this is what you're
not doing right so
yesterday i jumped on and i went into my
whole spiel hey thank you for joining
comment talk with the king it's gonna be
another exciting episode thank you for
tuning in to to the professional fan and
they said we can't hear
you we cannot hear you
so i didn't panic i didn't have to call
at it and i fixed it because why addict
taught me right so um
that's that's what he does facts he
takes the time out of his busy schedule
and he helps me out when i need him the
most and he's always there and it's a
fantastic thing quicker to shout out to
lady attic because i almost interrupted
day saturday every day day weekend
playing with my questions or for
technical stuff yeah so excited later
for dealing with my foolishness almost
interrupting a friday night continue
i don't do that i know i i i know dating
let it get stuffed
i don't bother adding on a friday night
because she knows this this part at this
point like i try to make her aware like
this is a job this is i try to explain
people that you know this this is a
package deal that's why
you're going to last to the relationship
if you're like this
but uh combat talk with the king
saturdays at uh 10 p.m
uh free drinks it's on me yummy you know
it's a good come in
just free drinks whatever you want to
drink bartender i'll send it to you you
get it first 200 people in huh
air shipping no no no first they're
virtually virtual okay we've
like y'all think you're really on your
digital games
yeah it's kind of like that but
different
you'll come in and hang out we saw some
we've been witnessing history uh
throughout this whole year and i think
uh boxing has a huge resurgence we had
two great fights last night and i jumped
from one fight to the x to the next to
the main event because the crowd acts so
and then you know i do play by play i do
blah blah blah pulse uh what people
don't understand what that is um
that's done
with with art and style so you got to
know
what's going on in the ring you got to
know how to interpret it to everybody
and also make it entertaining so it's
just me there talking to people for
three hours by myself
he said it was great
last night king missed his true calling
it said listen yes i had kids so
you know kids come first and then
whatever happens later but
you never know i might be out there with
al bernstein later on sometime
you never know showtime might call a kid
and then you know kid might have to call
us like how would coach sell i could
tell you right now so
call me fire buy it get out get them a
bag get them in the bag
you're gonna tell them the the the plans
with the call-in thing or well um i say
it on the show a lot yeah um
my plans is to have a level of uh
interaction with
you guys
and i'm talking about the extended
family because you guys extended family
right um
a level of uh connectivity and
interactivity with you guys that hasn't
been done yet
and we're going to do it
and it's going to be amazing because the
stuff is here i'm picking up some more
stuff and we're going to be in a relaxed
cool setting it's not going to be in in
the media room it's going to be in a
separate room i have many rooms here so
but it's going to be in that relaxed
setting because we're going to take it
to a whole different level places that
other people can't take it so we're
gonna have fun no doubt looking forward
to it and of course you already know
solutions love to solve you know what
i'm saying again he had to do the movie
there's some love man
oh yeah his back might be hurting
because he's carrying boxes the move
everybody man is going through a serious
move of a while i was on the show he was
moving too yeah yo it's funny yo every
time yeah you've been on he hasn't been
all over you i didn't realize that yeah
yeah yeah salute to something i know he
can't be i can tell you i was like
brother we got it but salute to him we
already know and his biggest fans showed
up was very disappointed so
can you play by joystick was very upset
keep in mind chad
next week we will be live streaming that
that event yeah so you know
i i i guess i i don't know but people in
the chats is the best place to watch
these offenses with the lord
come hang out come hang out 788 is still
that's crazy hit the like button um as
far as the super chat you're waiting for
these super chats
if we get these the 800
kids move we'll do cartwheels in this
room enjoy your night thank y'all for
spending the time with us we are not
going to hold your houses while we read
these chats not a problem love babe
yeah i'm out of here son no i know he
got i know maddie got stuff you got to
do it i know kid it's the same thing but
i love y'all what's up and no flame no
pole cause i know you rigging it and
there was no pole doing a prediction
show so i know what you're trying to do
anyway catch y'all all right let's get
these super chats i'll be out brother
let's do this stuff hi brother thank you
guys
i'ma sit here and laugh with the
commentary part yes or the situation
let's go even though i order pizza
what we got
all right so let me scroll through here
give me a couple seconds
trying to find where we left keep in
mind i know some of you did member chats
we can't see that like i'm trying to try
to help out too but yeah try to find any
member chat
yeah this is this is why we missed off
let's do it all right so let me
there's just so
many i'm going to stop that geeks to me
we got so many okay i'm coming close
coming close getting there just chumping
me up i got you want me to do hog hog
geeks to me let's make sure no just i'd
like to i prefer to do it in order i've
almost caught up to where he was yep
okay i think we were right
i i don't think we got italian clowns
did we um
yes i got him because he was clowning
lemon i remember him we got clowns okay
uh
so hollywood rules yes i'm just going to
read from here because yeah that's for a
fact queen right here yeah we got a 10
super chat from
right now cog wherever they do now from
here uh got it the last one you read
those on down i'm gonna read what's in
the past oh okay so we got a ten dollars
got it yeah the new stuff ten dollar
super chat from hollywood uh the last
one i have is 108 dragon tv that's the
last one i have
uh but we're gonna i'm gonna go ahead
and read from this uh this one right
here we got a ten dollar superchat from
hollywood rules jumped in the nyc video
game version of in-game my iop bros was
my fellow nypd
retired boom big tim dog and hip-hop
gamer awesome
king we want the hulk unboxing have a
great show
oh yeah shout out to hip-hop i forgot
so what's going on i got him i pulled up
that was crazy yeah got a 10 super chat
drawn tj you one of the best podcasts
out there salute out here bless him got
a five dollar super drive from bay air
area shout out to the lords booming
guest xbox but that's the game show
gonna be lit
we got a 20 superstar from corey hell
for an awesome show by the way i was
wondering who bought the lords of the
realms hoodie a few weeks back oh that
was you okay salute that's your shout
out correct
we got a five dollar super trout from
slo-mo backslap
going on vacation tomorrow bringing my
arena deck of where i can play
uh place xbox playstation switch games
natively and through cloud steam deck
e uh steve deck is better than the
switch he is messy because he's pc
bastards huh i said god bless with that
yeah he on his pc bastard has played
everybody exclusive stuff got a ten
dollar super trap from gamers play
zero hud zero what's up my gaming lords
this will be the xbox show to remember a
lot of golden moments to ion this is the
only begin this is only the beginning
because we have the next few shows too
he's got a point there but we talking
about this show this show right now
we got a
okay let me okay we gotta find out super
shot from uh from michael mooney
remember
fh uh forza horizon 5 has two expansions
to be revealed with its 15 million plus
uh players would you bury it with the
forza motorsports eighth this year
maybe
would you not have those or those
expansions gog
in this show yeah no put that expansion
up in there show them what else you
working on no no no
beat them over the head like you got a
five dollar screenshot from don otaku
why do we ignore flight sim as a series
x only game that's a good point because
people don't want to give credit to
where credit is due and they don't they
they still can't fathom that game
running on that system looking how it
does i'm not saying it doesn't deserve
to be one i'm just saying i want to see
something to appeal to me and that
metacritic didn't like it so let's go
what like what 15 people reviewed let's
go on
five dollars
from flame
how's it going realm i'm very excited
for the show it's only for the fact the
bar is set so low right now they can't
disappoint have a great show that's not
true
then we got a a 10 super trap from acg
he didn't say nothing but what i will
say
go check his last his last video out man
you really you really put a lot of time
in that go check this out the last time
people thought microsoft couldn't mess
up 2013 happened
let's go oh my gosh five dollars if you
try from john tj
sorry is in sony's in trouble
there are two six to ten first party
games coming out next year let that sink
in
we're talking about this they're
fighting too now don't don't think it's
gonna be a one-armed fight
you're swinging them bowls too now
and he's swinging it on pc hey man now
hey man five dollar super shot from
hustle and motivate yeah what's good
lords in chat attic you the real mvp
keep your fingers crossed for me i'll
know more info about my baby tomorrow oh
so uh so so what happened you also
having some mechanic issues
car car got a little messy oh god uh ho
ho everyone wish the best luck to hustle
in his vehicle tomorrow vehicle
situation yeah that there's always suck
man yeah well i gotta find out four
thousand stuff god bless man have fun
got a five dollar strat from heated
heavy 505.
we need a shirt with king and tim
standing back to back and it says stay
chill uh [ __ ] shilling oh yo stay
chillin
that's what's up
stay pocket watching
how about that we got that shirt right
now oh we got it oh
yeah son xbox a little heavy in that
underpants whoa wow
wow
that decided to be that fight wow it's
me
now i do want to point out before i keep
reading i did see a couple member chats
and there was a couple people that
entered the realm so if we can't get to
them put the logos in the chat at least
you know show them some respect man for
sure for the members so we got a five
dollar super chat from patrick not
trying to pronounce your last name we're
going with patrick i hope these rumors
about gears of war collection and banjo
remaster are true you see a banjo
remaster you're going to see me cry like
a little boy a little bit that's what we
get
just keep this in mind it's 15 a month
for game pass ultimate versus 30 a month
for game fly to get two games and it's
18
for playstation plus that's not even
worth it
600 games and game pass and more
coming two tell the truth saying the
devil let the world know the words
two slices of pizza talk we got a super
chat from zero
one i'm gonna call you zero on man you
guys know how it is dissing game pass is
laughable i just got me another three
year game pass for
117 dollars you gotta send me that link
[Laughter]
yes now
it's 45 years quickly
it's gonna uh fall short quickly okay we
got a two dollar super chat from john tj
bless him he's saying you're hilarious
king
king thank you sir king david is
hilarious yes we got a ten dollar super
chat from tron tj damn
three mic drop
announcements they announced ubisoft
plus the full version and game pass
ultimate second they bought a certain
infiniti
oh okay okay starting to find the third
okay the final splinter cell game pass
day one or mecca salt coming back that's
his man definitely you know uh obviously
we can't read the chat but if you want
to super check your predictions that's
perfectly fine that's fine oh five
dollar super chat from yambry uh farvay
uh definitely missed solve for that one
peace and blessing lords panel and chat
gotta acknowledge boom as the mayor of
speculation town yeah great show
reference to been dangerous
tim dawg
diller gonna let uh gonna get you he's
outside right now
you gotta run man
yeah dealer about to knock in that that
door swat style got a two dollar super
chat from don otaku yeah they're
starting with the vowel i'm calling so
dawn thinks they're starting
with the vowel okay i respect that i
think that's possible
we got a five dollar super from hector
the macho man
happy sunday lords king what are you
coming back to warner brothers games or
ttc
uh podcast so i think uh it's the uh wbg
what podcast
oh
tell people's names it's bg's podcast
it's kid's loose podcast
oh slow i know you want to messy about
spider-man going to pc do you want a
couple seconds to talk about spider-man
go on pc okay well it's not messy is i'm
i'll be able to play spider-man with my
xbox controller like i always wanted to
do
that's it there you go and there you go
and and i get to hear somebody cry in
the dark because i heard somebody yell
out
my franchise or my console
boy that's living forever
oh you gotta do it
because you know i love you and i'm
gonna tell you don't do it don't press
in don't press send
we got a five dollar super chat from
your baby farva
if my friends don't hype me up like cog
i don't want them that's it what spring
had me died
what you gonna do how you want that like
what the bite
for energy today i had to get the energy
up you know got a 20 super shot from jd
gamer
mr boom stick if netherrealm walks out
on stage and does that acquisition and
killer instinct reboot
i'm collecting and dumping knees off to
you
i'm too excited
and my blood pressure is going to make
my head explode who doesn't believe
we've got to get the party jumping bro
like
got a two super chat from captain chats
what boom said
but it's mk versus killer instinct game
i actually think that would make the
most sense because they would
incorporate killer instinct and then
they would start doing them individually
and then maybe every couple years they
do them together whoa um kind of like
they're doing justice
uh we got a
two a two dollar shot from shroom
kingdom
uh laugh my ass off and addicts not
gonna happen oh when i would say he said
mortal kombat not gonna happen
savage you got a two dollar chef from
lord metro would love to see esports
boxing club as well
[Music]
from gamer by choice lorecog is the best
hype man ever if it is not
if it does not work out he needs to pick
up for hyping games xbox hired this man
oh salute we got a five dollar street
version for necro
quarter four 20 22 and quarter one 20 23
will be looking strong for xbox with
these predictions yep oh yeah some of
those predictions i think you got to be
a little bit a little bit high to to
understand too
we got a five dollar from sage jiu jitsu
yeah
sage the man xbox and bethesda showcase
surprise final fantasy
16 day and date release alongside the
final fantasy version of the summer 2023
and it's only xbox game as day one
that's crazy
[Laughter]
we got a jd gamer with the five dollars
over 000 folks in the chat they hit that
like button xbox
say we're the only place to play all the
most popular shooters and western rpgs
this is true okay got another 5 super
chat from necromancer is it possible
dead space remaking game pass day date
announcement that would be crazy
interesting
it is an ea game
uh i don't know
ea usually tries to save that for their
service but i don't know i don't know
we'll see yeah we got a
okay we got to find out superchat from
uh jd gamer a valve's first showcase
july 2021 is 18 months enough time to
finish and polish the game to launch 11
11 2022
if not
when does it launch i don't know with
starfield getting delayed that makes it
very weird for a valve's release window
we'll have to see more on that hopefully
at the show
we got a five super chat from mr
irishman this prediction show is wild
either
part two gets announced or if a vow gets
dated for this year you can have my
knees and elbows yeah i remember that
one he was in the back
and then we got a five dollar street
trap from cat daddy lurk
stacks is what you used to call him yes
uh he says all of you
oh he's making fun of you for now
yeah yeah it's all
that's cool holly dude shout out to ali
and we got a two dollar super chat from
tx1138
tcl marketing enter the chat yeah yeah
yeah that's what that was good
okay then we got a five dollars
superchat from necromancer maddie it's
time you accept the burger surprise
shakespeare xbox's ear they
need respect for gaming uh for getting
us here then we got a two dollar super
chat from sosa predictions new crash
being shown in an exclusive oh
yeah with a two dollars from shroom
kingdom kojima gave you snake
but he is not your savior oh damn
108 dragon what would upset me is more
is talking more than gameplay videos
they put themselves under a microscope
bring the fire facts
five dollars super draft from parky
shanee i doubt you will see def loop
at the showcase the marketing rights
they likely they expire until september
so he's saying that sony probably has
exclusive rights to that uh that that's
all
[Music]
okay the next one right after that is
john wood 5 super chat my mic drop
addiction is phil announcing all og xbox
360 games are now backwardly compatible
put your discs in the tray and enjoy 20
years of xbox goodness thank you i think
that's over i don't think they're doing
much of that anymore okay so that was
the wolf he said yeah yeah okay now we
got it okay uh apollo cooper yeah thank
you yeah
yeah be mad if i see see at d i'll be
mad if i see sea of thieves expect
perfect dark gameplay and then shout out
to the inception ghost xbox expansion
pass throughout super chat salute you
already know salute salute and of course
108
back with dawson jack king got those nft
drinks who in
the drinks with the combat talk
and then now i think we are all caught
up yes and then the poll is complete
that um uh attic had is there going to
be persona 5 royale on xbox 52 percent
said yes 40 27 no so very neck and neck
750 715 votes very close tony he says
maddie
tony maddy was you just missed maddie he
was here you missed him he came through
he came a little late but he came
through about an hour now he's got about
an hour and a half he just messed up
yeah and then last thing the merch shot
to anonymous we've seen two people one
person got the classic white ilp logo
shirt the merch the drip is in there and
then someone else bought the the blue
joint all right go cop that okay another
one untitled 27 from twitter i remember
seeing you two pounds super chat can we
expect something from 343 and halo yeah
i told you already the single-player
campaign expanded i think they might
show that
the forge and um
no no i don't think i want to see none
of that
i do i want to see all of that because i
don't see that halo is
this is how next week's gonna work cog
will be out of town yes so i will be the
one
the stream will be going live an hour
early
because we're going to do something
similar with the community thing next
week as well might got some surprises
with you guys next week as well with
that uh so you be here about an hour
early and you know we're going to be
reacting to it called we'll be here
but he will be through his laptop he
won't be at his normal setup uh but i
will be hosting uh the show in terms of
most of the time with the events it
usually comes
yeah you host anyway so uh you know if
you guys have been the state of play i
usually do all that so we'll be here for
that i don't have a definite amount of
people that we're going to be here yet
so i'm still working through that on
who's going to be here obviously the
lord's it's all going to make it for
that yes i should be there yeah so saul
should be there for that we're gonna
have solve here king here cog here me uh
probably have three four you know guests
and then we'll have a pre-show obviously
next week's show is probably gonna be
four or five hours long because you're
incorporating the actual show
the hour before and maybe an hour and a
half make sure you bring your um your
diaper
[Laughter]
did they sell them they call the pan
they grow fast they put your diaper and
have juice and food i'm done put in the
put in the chat who would you guys like
to see in the reaction show no no no
this maximum is really expensive
reaction
[ __ ] watch the reaction
that would be ridiculous yo phil i think
you did a good one on that play right
there
crazy right
you ran the ball up the video
[Laughter]
i like that
imagine filling the chat be like down
now now you guys watch this watch this
one watch what we do right here
this is the part where i checked him and
i say yo let me see your bill
you see all you see is like the mic drop
moment phil just picks up a mic and
drops it
ah
halo is very very limited
i know you laughing because you're
playing it in this limited state you
don't care you're part of the problem
just like me
anyway so yeah it's gonna be a big one
you're still gonna be in the barrel i'll
be there adam will be hosting but yeah
i'll be uh orlando gtx if you're in gcx
um come holla at me it'll be a fun one
solve should be back we have some
special guests maybe some surprises
again feeling the post yeah realm
you got the rock you posted them
look everybody enjoy your sunday we out
of here peace
[Music]
hmm
so
[Music]
[Music]
oh